so of all people it's Mr Bill Gates who
said there is going to be a hung
election and there is going to be a
Civil War and I'm seeing these media
reports they're like Bill Bill Gates
says there may be a Civil War and then
I'm like really and then I read what he
actually said and he says there's going
to be a hung election and Civil War due
to political polarization and I was like
he's actually speaking a little bit more
definitively than that but at the same
time we're seeing people like Scott
Adams and Bill Burr saying like nah I
went outside and nobody's fighting and I
think that's just the absolutely
incorrect take for to Scott's credit he
was correct when he said Republicans
would be hunted although a bit I don't
know hyperbolic we have seen recently
with a guy in North Dakota running down
that kid and killing him so things are
getting pretty be crazy we now have
Politico writing a piece saying that we
must change the Constitution to stop one
man Donald Trump because they're insane
we're seeing what is it Michael Moore
that's the guy he says that Democrats
are going to win on a landslide against
the traitors but then Nancy Pelosi gets
booed on stage so I think all of this is
just really interesting at the same time
the economy is imploding the pound is
imploding Italy has elected a fascist
they're loving this right now because
it's like a far-right person in Italy
who won and so that's fascism I guess so
uh we got a lot to talk about before we
do my friends head over to
strongerbonesandlife.com and pick up
your ageless multi-collagen from
BioTrust this is stuff you need for your
joints your hair your skin and your
nails I was out there skating today so I
love this stuff because it keeps my
knees good and sometimes when I push it
too hard I can tell when I'm not getting
the right proteins because like my knee
will just hurt and it really is it it's
weird like that because it doesn't seem
like it would be but you know I don't
know I'm like I take the stuff and I
feel better 51 off when you go to
strongerbones in life.com you'll also
get a 60 day money back guarantee the
healthy aging support of collagen in its
ideal forms five key types of collagen
you need from four different sources
essential to optimally support an array
of full body benefits for every order
today BioTrust will donate a nutritious
meal to a hungry child in your honor to
their partnership with no kidhungry.org
to date BioTrust has provided over 5
million meals to Hungry kids please help
BioTrust hit their goal of 6 million
meals this year it is non-GMO and free
of artificial colors flavors
preservatives and sweeteners free of
gluten and about X and rbgh and RBST
nearly no odor or taste unlike bone
broth and other collagen supplements
there's no clumping like other
supplements you'll also get free
shipping with every order and free VIP
live health and fitness coaching from
BioTrust team of expert nutrition and
health coaches for life with every order
and their new e-report the 14 foods for
amazing skin with every order again head
over to strongerbonesandlife.com thank
you so much BioTrust we love you guys
sponsored a ton of our shows and we're
grateful to have you and also go to
timcast.com
join us by clicking the join us button
we're going to have an uncensored
members only show coming up tonight at
11 PM those are always wacky and fun and
we swear a lot so we look forward to
having you there plus as a member you're
supporting our news team they do all of
this hard work just for you as members
that's it that's how we support it
because we believe in it so as a member
we're going to make sure that we're
doing good work fact checking all the BS
and uh standing up to the corporate
establishment joining us today to talk
about oh wait wait smash the like button
subscribe to the channel share the show
with your friends joining us today to
talk about all this is everyone's
favorite Libby Evans hello hello Libby
Emmons editor-in-chief with the post
millennial glad to be here thank you for
coming it's always great it's always
good to have you thanks and of course we
have the T-shirt Merchant himself
oh oh hey hey guys I didn't see you guys
there I'm just uh partly sick and tired
of someone here getting all the
attention so I gotta sell some shirts so
we gotta you know I got my Bill Gates
trendy bazunkas on and the the shirt
that I'm proudly wearing today says the
great resist they will own nobody and
they will be unhappy which you could
exclusively get on the best
politicalshirts.com you gotta lift and
separate there this is hey look what
does that shame me what are those eggs
right here you're a little uneven no
who are you to say
getting all this attention and then he
comes out of the bathroom looking like
this I could help myself hey who gets
attention hey hey this is trendy right
now right this is what your Peak male
masculinity testosterone looks like
right now face it that's the reality I
like the way you control your own body
thank you very much Ian but you know I
feel liberated right now there's people
listening on like iTunes or something
and they're just like what are they
talking about I could understand why
these are so popular I mean yes
this is like the Classic Auto Ghana file
over here
it was funny when Luke came out and
Libby was like you need to lift and
separate to lose yeah and he doesn't
know what he's doing so they're all like
yeah they're all crooked hey I could
help you but I don't want to be accused
of harassment yeah I'm watching you
yeah if you didn't hear there was a
tropical storm upgrade to I think a
level one hurricane called Ian going
towards Florida so I'm going to do
everything in my power to meditate and
create some sort of polarization in the
clouds above those winds to dissipate
the storm which which rock will help you
do it uh any kind of Crystal I would
imagine so quartz we got quartz crystal
here another rose quartz there I'm glad
that I live in a country that won't
stream me up for being a heretic for
talking about stuff like this you know
we can be crazy and talk about weird and
funny ideas in the United States it's a
it's a beautiful thing so let's keep
that tradition going that's the key
thing yeah that's all I got for the
moment we need all the ends to join
together and figure out how to stop this
storm so that my guests from Florida can
get here tomorrow very excited let's get
going let's talk about it all so here's
a story from Business Insider Bill Gates
says political polarization may bring it
all to an end and could even lead to a
Civil War I saw this headline and I was
like wow that's really interesting thing
of him to say but so what a lot of
people have said that and then I
actually scroll down and read the quote
he says I admit that political
polarization may bring it all to an end
we're going to have a hung election and
a civil war yet he didn't say we might
he he says we are we are going to have a
hung election in a civil war now I
wonder could this be because Bill Gates
reads the bulwark because we we talked
about that last week and I don't know if
you saw the story The bulwark published
an article about how the Civil War could
start
and I think they make an interesting
point that come the midterms you've get
you've got right wing people and
left-wing people showing up to the polls
duh it's an election and they're
accusing each other of impropriety or
something a fight breaks out someone's
arm someone gets shot there's a viral
video of someone being killed in a
polling place that's what the bulwark
said I don't know for sure but I am I I
do think that if you already have people
who don't trust the election they're of
course going to show up to polling
places I mean what even five people
maybe at each place and then you're
going to get antifa types and leftist
types and they're going to show up as
well and then and then what happens well
his comments are very important here
because he said specifically I quote I
have no experience with it I'm not going
to put my money on it because I don't
know how to spend it saying pretty much
that it's guaranteed but then he also
went on and later made the points that
it's polarization and the lack of trust
that is the main problem specifically
pointing at Robert Kennedy as someone
who of course criticized him and and
he's using this this concern which a
large majority of the American people
have a lot of people think there's going
to be a Civil War in this country
according to many polls he's using this
fear in order to Galvanize pressure on
people criticizing him so this is
another aspect to also understand here
with his latest kind of salacious
comments I love this idea like Bill
Gates is sitting in his living room like
watching TV and then he's then he just
comes across this new like a news story
about Robert Kennedy criticizing him and
he goes he said what about me there's
going to be a Civil War in this country
the article also talks about how they're
how part of the problem is
misinformation right and we know that
misinformation is a catch-all term that
is used to describe anything that the
left doesn't agree with yeah you know
here's my here's my favorite part though
he says quote I have no expertise in
that I'm not going to divert my money to
that because I wouldn't know how to
spend it says the guy who owns more
Farmland than anyone else in the United
States yeah I start to wonder about that
because when he started buying up
Farmland we talked about it right and we
were like creepy why is he doing this
right good investment maybe now he's
like oh yeah and by the way there's
going to be a Civil War and it's like is
is that why you're because here's what I
said when he was like I wouldn't know
what to do I said it's simple like build
a bunker I mean what I actually said was
get a get a corporate laundromat and
hire eight German guys to start digging
underneath one of your machines you know
for you you know he's watching Better
Call Saul so yeah I mean he's also
working on a lot of interesting projects
he's introducing a new kind of patented
patented GMO corn into Africa which
allegedly is going to be helping them
deal with hunger and the climate and in
reality he wants to get people off of
meat he wants people to stop using cows
chickens uh pigs in order to fight
climate change and he's doing this with
GMO corn is this corn gonna be the kind
that has no seeds you know how there was
like Monsanto Monsanto seeds that yeah
that that did that specifically so
farmers had to keep buying it from them
farmers were sued even for
cross-pollination exactly previously
before it's still unknown the details of
what's Happening Here but Bill Gates was
one of the major backers of Monsanto
which introduced corn which is heavily
subsidized and creates high fructose
corn syrup which is banned in many
places around the world so wait wait
wait they produced corn that made no
seeds
um they produced a number of of
agriculture products that produced no
seeds so the farmer always had to buy
and be dependent and I know there's like
seedless watermelon I'm just imagining
I'm wondering about how corn seedless
corn would work since all corn is seeds
right so I think as I said trying to
visualize yeah yeah well I mean it's
it's the it's sterilized yeah yeah yeah
yeah so it's getting regrow yeah yeah so
but I'm wondering I mean like uh
seedless fruits things like that we have
seedless grapes I'm just wondering like
it's like I'm imagining a dystopian
future where people find seats and
they're like we're safe and they plant
them and they get one crop and then
there's no reproduction and there's
nothing yeah exactly and it's over yeah
that's why they have uh they have those
seed
vaults in the Arctic right yeah it's in
what is that Norway or is it I think
it's Norway is it Norway savalabarden
yeah the seed Vault where they store all
those seeds because I guess uh we don't
want to die yeah we don't want to die I
think it's a good idea humans are quite
fond of living yes
but but as he's trying to push for
climate change telling people not to eat
uh real meat he also has 100 patents on
synthetic uh Meats on synthetic cheeses
he also has a lot of intellectual
property and and he's he he literally
just came out a couple months ago and
said rich countries need to switch to
completely synthetic beef which of
course would greatly benefit him more
than anyone else so so we have to start
thinking about why he made these
comments now about Civil War and what's
the greater benefit to him as of course
it's also important to note here that he
is a man that has finance and funneled
hundreds of millions of dollars into the
corporate media that literally acts like
his PR marketing team that regurgitates
all of his larger business proposals and
sells it to the American and intern
national public the guardian of the BBC
MSNBC many organizations are directly
financed by Bill Gates and this is why
you can't trust any legitimate news
coverage as well as also the fact
Checkers that of course attack any
criticism of him which is absolutely uh
dystopian and ridiculous to live in such
a world where we can't even criticize
this billionaire that is best friends
with Jeffrey Epstein I just
say they don't think Civil War is
possible and stuff and I'm just like
more and more people are are each
other's throughouts more and more people
are accusing each other of being evil it
doesn't matter if you're right or
they're right you know we think we're
right I think we have evidence to back
it up we don't we don't fall for the
hoaxes Like Jesse Smith or the Covington
kids or the Duke best the Duke
volleyball thing Duke volleyball the
lacrosse thing no the volleyball thing
oh yes but then there was the young
woman who said that she was the
volleyball player and she was out at BYU
and there was a racial slur there was a
racial slur and that people were calling
her racial slurs the whole time and
after an investigation it turned out
nobody else had heard it at all right so
so these no one had said but the
corporate media ran with it like it was
a real story even though it was a public
event in front of other people and I
remember looking at that story when it
came out and we were like uh we're gonna
hold on this because I bet this is a
hoax and then sure enough it was so this
is the point I mean we sit here we read
the news we're like okay these things
are probably fake oh here's another
story that's probably fake we're going
to wait for evidence
the other side is just like must be true
let's roll around with it it doesn't
matter who actually is right though
truth is irrelevant as much as I think
truth matters for us in terms of will a
Civil War happen the truth is
meaningless and it's exemplified very
simply if you go to one of these people
and say
um here's the truth they go don't care
you know that people are yes that does
happen that makes it all the more
important for us to hold on to reality
and hold on to the truth I agree to
stand on it you have to stand on the
truth that for for existence and reality
the truth matters what I'm saying is in
terms of will there be a civil war it
doesn't matter if you hold the truth or
they hold the truth because they are
zealots who will Who will believe
whatever is placed in front of them so
you can go to them as an outsider Like
Larry I think it was Larry Elder
pointing this out and show them here is
the transcript from the New York Times
of trump saying condemn the white
supremacist and they go I don't care I
don't want to hear it right because they
don't think that it matches what they
believe already I mean a civil war
though like you know you and I were
talking about this before we aired and
the people who are like oh I walk
outside and nobody's angry at each other
there's no fighting in the street a
civil war wouldn't be like fighting in
the street people would arm up go to
their separate camps you know like go to
their separate areas or whatever well no
no sort of we have this tweet here from
Scott Adams and he says there won't be a
Civil War in the United States not even
close there is no appetite for it
outside Twitter imagination one person
said your source and his response was
walking outside wasn't he earlier just
saying that people are going to be shot
in the streets he was saying Republicans
will be hunted and then like we did see
that happen on a couple occasions so I
don't know why he's changing his mind
the other thing though is what I
responded to him was
what about walking outside in Portland
La Chicago or New York with a trump
shirt on but I agree Scott Adams uh may
be right it could just be a slow
revolution of authoritarian Powers
because the right doesn't want to fight
but here's the point I made
imagine it's eight it's January 1861.
and a guy in Atlanta walks out of his
house and he's fuming he's like oh I
just read the paper and I hate those
Yankees oh and then he walks up to his
neighbor and punches his Southern
neighbor in the face why would he do
that his neighbor agrees with him of
course you can walk outside and no one's
fighting like people in New York agreed
with each other they were cheering on
the the uh what was it it was the the
dude it was a southern dude who caned a
northern guy right I think it was the
caning no I don't remember their names
but like one side was cheering it on one
side was condemning it so yeah in the
South you walked outside and everyone
was like it was bad that happened and
then people in the north were like it
was good that happened or I think it's
inverted the point is yeah you surprised
that you walked outside in like 80
percent Democrat New York and nobody's
fighting each other okay well put on a
put on a Maga hat like Blair white did
walk around L.A and see how long it
takes until they attack you because they
did Blair got attacked this was years
ago so yeah
you can get attacked I'm not saying
that's proof Civil War is going to
happen I think we look at what the FBI
is doing and we're like oh I mean
certainly the FBI going after they just
rated the home of a pro-life activist
right that was crazy absolutely insane
over over like because they're like it's
a
um the face act because you assaulted
somebody who was working at an abortion
clinic even though the charges were
dismissed by a court right right and
this is like what years later or
something right one year so you know
when I see the FBI weaponize and going
after run-of-the-mill conservatives just
like this is like a regular person this
is not like a politician my immediate
instinct is instinct is Civil War but my
point here is that no no Scott might be
right you know conservatives in the
right might just you know get on their
knees and say you know I'm so sorry
please I don't want to fight well we
have been doing that for a while that's
been going on look I understand about
the thing about saying that it's all
just happening on Twitter though is
Twitter is our Collective imagination
you know like it it's debatable but you
know I think it's there as part of what
we are imagining and what we believe and
it's a it's a where we're exploring
ideas in real time we're certainly not
doing that in any other aspect of our
society that's not happening in books
that's not happening in movies or TV or
on the news we're exploring ideas in
real time and Twitter has a direct
impact on how Democrats are spending
money yeah they see the the tweets the
Bots and everything and they say this is
what we should promote and then all of a
sudden the Democrats are advocating for
child's child sex changes right so like
and then saying that they're not and
then saying actually they are good you
know the New York Times was defending
them today exactly the New York Times
put out an article saying yeah actually
these things do happen right yeah
because they have to do it they said
they said it does happen and this doctor
who finds most of her clients on Tick
Tock is doing great things with
marketing on social media meanwhile they
were censoring and blacklisting and
destroying people's lives because they
were saying that a few weeks ago they
were saying no this is not true they're
literally a few weeks ago yes like two
weeks ago citing violence and then
there's like oh no no it's good no
hospitals are chopping off girls boobs
when they're 14. oh wait it's good that
they are they are right it's good I
think when it comes to like will there
won't there be some sort of civil
conflict that escalates it's basically a
morale question of morale if people get
broken morally and then they they'll
just resort to The Last Resort which is
always violence so and people in America
are generally pretty high morale because
we have it awesome here like fresh water
good food warm buildings
um transportation if you destruct I
think if we didn't have that stuff it
would be way easier to spiral into Decay
mentally
um and then what other choice do you
have it is sort of a luxurious culture I
was talking to a friend of mine from
Morocco the other day we were like yes
it's unbelievable the Bounty at the
grocery stores you know that we can get
anywhere that everything is you know we
have fresh water all of these things
this is a story I like to tell about
when I was in Brazil that many people
listen I've probably heard but for those
that haven't I was at a favela where
they couldn't flush their toilet and it
was just all of the family's waste
piling up because they need rain so they
had no water and I was like you have a
bathroom like right there and I'm like I
ain't going anywhere near that thing so
they have it rough and then the the
mother asks something in Portuguese and
then you know my friend translated and
he says she's asking you why the rich
people are protesting in America and
then I was like what do you mean and he
asked her and she says blah blah blah
blah he goes Occupy Wall Street you know
like the people they're protesting and I
went it's not the rich people protesting
it's like young people college kids like
Working Class People they're upset
because the corporations were getting
bailouts from the government the
government was giving them money and the
banks so basically they feel like
they're not getting their fair share and
then he tells her and then she laughs
and she says she says something and he
goes she said all Americans are rich
pretty much and I was like I would agree
with that to a certain extent from her
perspective she's like these people have
like clean running water and in like
their lowliest of Apartments like even
the bad Apartments have clean running
water I mean yes we have we have poverty
and we all have all of that but we do
have a very high standard of living
across the board I think when and we've
done great things to get rid of child
poverty I think that's true yeah every
day we still I am I mean this is just
when I think about like will there won't
there I feel very much like we are and
maybe not in control but influencing it
because it's like a morale system well
and one thing that had such a huge
impact on on that obviously is fossil
fuel
you know fossil fuel was responsible for
uh oh yeah decreasing poverty globally
for decreasing poverty in the U.S and
creating seven billion people yes when
you look at the the Advent of the
petroleum industry human population goes
good straight and that's what we have I
mean the isn't the Petro dollar what we
really have to thank for our wealth too
so I have to wonder when you get someone
like Bill Gates who's like climate
change over and over again when they
want to get rid of fossil fuels it
sounds like what they're really saying
is like yo we use too much energy too
quick and now there's too much going on
we have too many people there's too much
activity there's too much Freedom
there's too much Prosperity we must have
it all for ourselves and this kind of
egomaniac kind of idea like I mean look
most likely the planet is suffering but
why should I give up my pain it's
suffering because of them and what
they're doing to the environment
Jets they live in the Mansions they they
boat around in the little Yachts as of
course they go to China exploit slave
labor and all the non-regulations there
that they called for and put up and set
up there Bill Gates literally advises
the Chinese government what else do you
need to know about what he's really
behind and what he's really doing he
complimented the Chinese government said
they did a good job with covid okay I
want to jump to these next stories
because I want to keep it on track
there's a tweet from Logan Hall Logan
Clark Hall he's the um digital at
thenewfounding.org and used to be the
Daily Caller he said seems like Biden's
speech equating conservatives with
terrorists worked as intended September
24th elderly pro-life volunteer in
Michigan shot after heated conversation
pro-life group says the elderly Michigan
woman was going door to door discussing
a ballot proposal on abortion then we
have Pennsylvania pro-life activists
arrested by FBI charged with assaulting
a clinic escort prosecutors say Mark
Houck twice assaulted a man outside a
Planned Parenthood clinic on the same
day last year it's overtly partisan then
of course we have Kaylor elsing
ellingson's alleged killer not under
house arrest no curfew after posting
very low Bond former assistant U.S
attorney says the very low bond is
woefully adequate not only that but I
was reading that the guy who killed that
that the 18 year old kid who was killed
and the guy said he was a republican
extremist I read that in his bail
hearing he was shocked that the courts
were holding it against him like
apparently he he assumed they'd
congratulate him or something or be
alive Kevin killed the kids yes for
having killed an 18 year old like so uh
one of the articles I read said he he
expressed shock at that he would be held
accountable for killing this 18 year old
kid that's one way to try and defend
yourself so
pro-lifer being shot yeah it really does
sound like
it works at face value it does but I
want to see like when they say heated
conversation like was the guy like come
on like how he did what was he screaming
old lady that shot him no I don't know
who yelled I think they're talking about
the 18 year old that got killed the
story
early
heated conversation yes elderly what's
this he did yeah well I mean I've seen
some nasty oh come on dude 84. oh my
goodness 84 year old woman being like
stop killing babies and you're like all
right she's gotta go like that's what I
mean you have the right to free speech
but you also there's consequences to get
in people's face so yeah but what's the
story you shouldn't shoot old ladies I
think is a general rule in society right
I gotta I want to see me okay but it was
she was an unarmed old lady knocking on
doors like you don't answer the door
people knock on my door I don't ever
answer my door ever uh I would love to
go deeper into that story to be honest
the the heated conversation
because man the news just does spin
stuff oh boy okay so here's the story
from uh Yahoo results are changing
quickly does an elderly pro-life
volunteer in Michigan was shot in the
shoulder while canvassing a neighborhood
to discuss an abortion about proposal
according to the right to life in
Michigan the victim said she was shot in
the back slash shoulder while leaving a
residence during a heated conversation
and that the man who shot her was not
part of the conversation
the unidentified woman is 83 years old
according to police so the right to life
of Michigan identified as 84 years old
in a press release the wind was
campusing a neighborhood in Lake Odessa
to discuss the state's voting proposal 3
which would protect abortion access in
the state the state will vote on The
Proposal November 8th
the victim does not know the Identity or
motive of the shooter a for shooter the
victim is still recovering from her
gunshot wound and wishes to remain
anonymous while the criminal
investigation proceeds now this is just
according to right to life so I think if
she wants to have a bigger political
impact she needs to come forward and
explain what happened and we need to be
able to get to to investigate this well
I mean that clearly shows that she
wasn't aggressing or moving towards
somebody since the Bullet Hole is is
there uh so so that that pretty much
says it all like what kind of coward
shoots an old lady in the back I don't
know someone that wasn't even involved
in the conversation exactly yeah did you
see the video there was another video
where a woman is going door to door and
then the lady starts screaming at her
and chases her off the property I
haven't seen that I just gotta say like
you know to Scott Adams when he tweeted
that Republicans would be hunted
everyone kind of rolled their eyes and
they were like whoa a little over the
top there Scott and then we actually saw
people get shot and killed right beaten
up chased and then we were around with a
car and now and now more recently run
down with a car and we're like yeah
actually it may have seemed a little
little bombastic but it is starting to
happen now for Scott to come out and be
like neighbors aren't attacking each
other and I'm like yo this old ladies
got shot in the back do you guys think
it kind of is we're canvassing and
having political discussions with people
do you think that hate is ever good
hate knows of course what do you mean I
don't think hate is a good thing I hate
rabid dogs I mean like right but what's
the use of hating them why is that
better than not just like any emotion it
serves yeah but like but okay I I think
the idea is like irrational hate is bad
right but hate from a logical place like
they're they're they're they're really
extreme emotion like what's the what's
the use of it to keep you safe so for
example like why do we feel sick looking
at like a a dead animal because we have
a natural response to that
to feel sick and want to be away from it
and vomit why because it's got disease
and and infection and things like that
and so the humans that were not
disgusted by it may have eaten it and
been contaminated and died and those who
were disgusted by it and vomited who so
the vomiting is clear I mean I'm not an
evolutionary biologist but yeah this is
more of a disgust thing than a hate
thing right the point of hate is like
there could be a certain thing being
done by
name name name creature yeah rabbit
dog's a good one attacking a family
member like there might be someone who's
like I just hate these these these Wild
Hogs
I need my number 15. back in the day
you'd see a wild hog and you'd get angry
and then you'd stop it before it
destroyed your crops or harmed your
family you could just be logical about
it too like I don't think your emotions
are better emotions hate human human
emotion you know comes from this place
of what you know of survival so I wonder
love things that help us and protect us
and make us feel good and we hate things
that hurt us and and cause if you have
like a rabid dog that was threatening
your your family and about to kill them
you could logically destroy the rabid
dog without any emotional attached
because you know it's the right thing to
do it's starting to feel like hate
towards it feels like it's taking over
I'll give you a better example a guy and
his daughter out in the backyard and
they're playing with a frisbee when a
rabid dog runs up and bites her neck
ripping severing her carotid and she
bleeds out in 20 seconds he then says I
hate that dog and he starts a whole
Revenge plot where he goes and buys a
bunch of guns and he's got a board
tracking the dog and then he hunts it
down he goes Revenge when he puts it
down that hatred he felt saved another
child from being killed by that rabid
dog that's the point yeah there's like
movies about like some uh Jason no not
Jason Bourne it was that Keanu Reeves
movie where someone kills his dog and
then he goes on a revenge and it's like
glorifying hate is it a little different
was he feeling hate he was feeling hate
towards the people that killed his dog
and that and that is it's a little more
extreme but it is a good point that
those were really bad people who broke
into his house beat him and killed the
dog you went extreme with it like yeah
no they killed this dog like come on
like I mean like what do you think
there's do you think it's a reasonable
movies
dozens of people over his side do you
think that it's reasonable to hate
someone who disagrees with you over
political matter like is that something
that is a worthwhile undertaking hate
and wild card what do you mean by
worthwhile undertaking well I think I
think hate is totally fine I think you
just don't want to attack people and you
want to be reasonable like you're
allowed to hate people hate is a hate is
a fine emotion but you should be
rational about it and you you shouldn't
act you shouldn't act out upon it so you
can be like yo I just really hate people
who throw litter out of their cars and
don't care and are polluting everything
like I genuinely despise that yeah
you hate reaction no no people who gloat
and laugh as they throw waste do you see
people gloating and laughing I see
people actually you know what I really
hate actually I will use the term is uh
parents will show their kids to throw
trash on the street in Brooklyn and that
really makes my blood boil my point is
like there are things that we
universally despise like a serial killer
who gloats about murdering like I hate
that person like I genuinely despise
people who want to victimize I don't
like uh violent like you see that video
of the guy in the convenience store
imagine the store clerk is on his knees
and the guy walks up behind him and the
store looks like give him whatever he
wants and then the dude just kills him
anyway I genuinely hate that guy yeah
what that means is I think about what he
did I think about what he believes in
and who he is and I hate everything
about what brought him to that point and
and that guy right now hate him
so you gotta be reasonable about it
reasonable about it what we don't want
is irrational hatred where you just hate
someone because of the way they look
it's rational I don't think it's
rational it literally it's an emotional
discharge okay so this guy literally
shot and killed the dude on his knees
who was cooperating so if you were like
a military commander you'd be like we
need to execute the the threat but
you're not like rage don't change the
subjects well if you're if you're gonna
walk like I walked into exclusively
handling it a guy walked into a store
and aggressed upon another person who
complied and killed him for no reason
yes I hate that person but like and the
response should be we need to stop them
with that hatred and that anger that I
feel it is what is the appropriate way
to stop a person like this and how do we
prevent it from happening in the future
that hatred is what leads us to stopping
the thing from happening you can do it
without hate too vengeance is very
dangerous because when someone's becomes
emotional we're talking about
emotionally charged responses it's not
the same thing we're not talking about
the same thing hateful response is a
form of venge is a form of Revenge
Revenge on the guy want him to be
stopped yeah yeah this might be a
definitional issue maybe yeah semantics
I think hate I think that's fine it's an
emotion it's fine you're allowed to feel
emotions emotions serve a purpose and
they're part of The Human Experience
yeah but emotional leaders are dangerous
like I haters I hate wasps like I I
actually like those people from New
England
singing venomous insects okay they like
they don't make honey like what are they
even doing I don't know what wasps are
okay
chasing me yesterday
some wasps killed by other bugs I'm fine
with that like stink bugs the reason we
have stink bug problem now in the east
coast is because they're native to China
and there's a wasp in China that hunts
them in the air and so he kills them in
the air we don't need to bring those
we don't need those
like the stink bugs are at least stink
bugs are at least cute like they're
doofy and they like walk around and they
clap for you you ever see the stink bugs
clap sink bugs no but I saw spider
cricket yesterday and that freaked we
got a bunch of those what the oh did not
like it yeah they're all Cricket there's
like 7 000 in the skate parks I was
reaching into a bucket to get some goat
food and there was a spider cricket so
so listen why do I hate wasps because
they don't do anything good for me they
build nests they attack people they
swarm and when they sting you you go to
the hospital yeah it's bad so like I
have a very negative emotional reaction
to them and when I see them I'm like I
must remove that wasp's nest they can
build anywhere off my front porch but
now they're building on my front porch
so we have to get wasp spray it's a
whole thing yeah that's not a hate
that's not real hate there was a mouse
origin the other day I kind of hated it
and but it was also sort of cute but I
still hated it people have pets as Mouse
even I didn't I don't need a I don't
need a feral Mouse as a pet living in my
kitchen
was unpleasant I guess it maybe we're
just talking about different definitions
of the word hate because like I think
you and I are talking eradicating
similar infestation which is why I said
hate is fine but irrational hate is
irrational well so and acting acting out
in a negative way because of hatred is
also look you feel so you have these
humans feel emotions you're allowed to
feel them they're all good so you have
the Michigan guy is doing irrational
hate just like the North Dakota guy
irrational hate no no no no no no you
don't think these guys are reactions are
the problem not the emotion you can feel
however you do you think this guy had a
rational hate this uh Michigan old lady
shooter yes irrational but the problem
isn't just that he's irrational and
hatred the problem is that he shot
someone like if you're outside and
you're going oh I'm just so full of hate
I'd be like well you know enjoy it yeah
I mean some people have a good time sure
that's that's it maybe that's their
Baseline look it's part of the human
experience to feel ways about things
like if we were just like we shouldn't
feel hate is bad let's just be logical
beings it's like okay come on you know
like we experience life in a variety of
ways and some people are more hateful
than others but I think hate love fear
all these things we chase fear is fear
bad people jump off buildings on purpose
because you get that Adrenaline Rush
that fear and then you survive it yeah
but it's also jumping off a building who
does that are you joking surviving
jumping off buildings uh-huh oh like if
you repel off buildings like base
jumping oh yeah I hate that bungee
jumping but anyway I think it's also
important to note here that that people
can't control their emotions more and
more a lot of people's nervous systems
are fried doctors are being told by
medical boards to ask everyone if they
have anxiety I think there also is a um
not only a mental health crisis but a
physical health crisis that is leading
to a lot of the insanity that we're
dealing with the consequences of in the
streets in New York City in San
Francisco that that truly is a way
bigger problem very much complex and I
think it all boils down to a lot of food
being poisoned a lot of individuals not
having a good mental health and not
controlling their emotions and then
lashing out and acting crazy which we're
seeing more and more of on on big Tech
social media and whether we're seeing it
deliberately because social media wants
to show it uh to us specifically or
whether it's really happening I I think
it still deserves to be talked about
from a fair perspective because there
are a lot of people struggling out there
that do need help I had um we have I
want to jump to this next story
yeah about just about like on Friday we
had a show with Nick palmisano was on
the show and it was I had a hard time
with it I felt like I was going to puke
for a lot of it because you and him were
going deep and you guys were really
going at each other about Civil War and
why not and why is why not why maybe why
no and so I was like just in a nasty
mood this weekend like that that energy
I carried in I was stressed out like
what are we doing are we propagating
this thing without realizing it and then
I heard about the storm called Ian
coming and part of me was like fine let
the storm let the storm land and I'm
like what am I doing what have I become
am I like becoming the evil that I that
I hate and so I had to change my
emotions I I disengaged from the machine
meaning my computer I cleared my mind
and just thought about dissipating the
clouds and had to like re-navigate my
own emotions which I do believe is
possible which is why I think if you
feel hate you could change it that's why
we got we got a hat trick for you let's
get on with his next these next stories
we got this one from timcast.com quote
they will lose and they know it
Democrats will lose if election is a
referendum on Biden saki says follow the
money said the former uh press secretary
she says if it's a referendum on Biden
they're going to lose but if it's a
referendum on extremism they're gonna
win all right here's the next story
Michael Moore predicts Democrat
Landslide against the traitors
Friday nhpo's real-time liberal
documentary filmmaker Michael Moore
defied conventional wisdom and predicted
a landslide victory for Democrats in
November's midterm election
there are so many signs of this I think
honestly I think if we all do our work
and we all get people out to get out
there and we get ourselves I think we
can throw out a huge number of these
Republican traders in November he says I
think that there's going to be such a
landslide against the Traders especially
the 147 Republicans who just hours at
the Insurrection voted to not certify
the elected president of the United
States Joe Biden I think there's going
to be so many people coming out to vote
and then lastly with the hat trick from
the conservative brief pollster GOP
midterm turnout will exceed already high
expectations as parties fortunes grow so
what's it going to be huh saki says if
it's about extremism they win if it's
about Biden they lose Michael Moore says
the Democrats are going to win and then
this uh this pollster is saying that the
Republicans are going to win so uh what
what is it what do we got
yeah it's really hard to say I mean uh
it was uh Joe Rogan
um and another uh very popular
commentator I forgot his name right now
I'm blanking right now that that also
was from the left that came out and said
hey everyone should vote Republican for
this upcoming midterm it's going to be
wasn't that that was row again and
somebody else I forgot what's polinski
it was somebody it was somebody else
coming from a very surprising figure
that that you know shocked a lot of
people that that this person actually
said this I I have it somewhere here in
my notes uh but but it's going to be
interesting to see the turnout to see if
people actually do decide to vote or
whether they're just so disenfranchised
with this kind of emotional manipulation
that they're trying to tune out Aaron
Rodgers
commentator and I was like I thought it
was Aaron Rodgers it was yeah Aaron
Rodgers on Rogan but you know what was
interesting is that I think it does have
to do with if people are going to turn
out so many people are dissatisfied
nothing really seems to be going right
in the country you have Biden's really
horrible speech with his blood red
background you know speaking in front of
the Independence Hall I found it really
troubling that speech and I think a lot
of people did I talked to Democrats who
also found it troubling for different
reasons but
believed that it would be effective for
you know Democrats to be motivated to go
vote and I think it was to a certain
extent motivating for them the GOP I
think really should lean into the issues
that Americans care about McCarthy like
barely made any noise the other day even
though he gave that whole speech but you
did see him starting to unite a little
bit with the new right he had MTG
sitting right behind him in a pink
Blazer I was really glad to see her
there she's someone who initially I was
like I'm not so sure and I've really
come to have a lot of uh you know a lot
of respect for her I like her a lot so
um I liked to see that I like to see
that being a little more unified but I
think they have to lean more into the
new right stuff than the establishment
stuff well the the issue is that the
what people care about doesn't generate
clicks so if you're like let's talk
about economics the average the average
person is not going to share a story
that says like here's how we improve the
economy right what's going to get shares
is like Trump supporters are fascists
and Democrats are giving children sex
changes right so those end up becoming
dominant issues and I'm not sure if
you've experienced this too but stories
about the border which people do say
they care about immigration border
stories like don't get a ton of shares
either why do you think that is I think
because it's super depressing to see
little kids abandoned at the border I
don't think we've had any reasonable
solutions that have been enacted other
than you know I mean during the Trump
years it slowed down substantially I
think
um but it I just don't think it's an
issue that people want to deal with I
think people are primarily conflicted
about it and it's cognitive dissonance
yeah I think there's something like that
going on I think what I'm going to be
looking for in this upcoming midterm is
is one how many people come out two how
effective is social media going to be
and big and corporate media in in
swaying the emotions of people to vote a
particular way I think it's going to be
very interestingly because historically
uh the president's party loses the
midterms uh almost every time uh
throughout the the midterms that always
happened throughout uh you know the
latest uh the races that happened to
Obama right it happened to Obama that
happened I think to Bush as well uh it
happened 17 out of the 19 times uh since
the last last time so sorry the bazunkas
are I know I keep looking at a hard time
I'm actually wondering like is it is it
having an impact I think so I mean
there's Aaron Rodgers right behind me
and I was like who is that I don't know
I'm acting like a boob you're having
like baby brain over there I know I
don't know it happens it's it's you know
the power it gets to me here preparing
to be a parent
maybe I won't tell anyone my private
life but that's what yeah what we're
talking about here looking great now the
midterms here as we're trying to focus
here Ian before the show when when Luke
walks out with the fake boobs and goes
this is looking good
I should have wore a v-neck but uh
anyway uh it is going to be interesting
because it is going to going to tell a
lot and it's going to foreshadow what's
going to be happening in 2024. so who's
going to have the power who's going to
have the influence who's going to have
you know the authority moving forward in
this country I think is going to dictate
a lot of uh you know a lot of the very
important like I just want to say you
know in 2020 Texas filed a lawsuit
against Pennsylvania and you had about I
think 46 states signed on to one side of
the lawsuit or the other questioning or
opposing the results of the election due
to uh procedural changes in certain
States so the Texas V Pennsylvania State
uh suit was specifically how
Pennsylvania handled the election
nothing to do with fraud it was about
like can you have Universal mail and
voting in Texas was like
uh the Supreme Court said they wouldn't
hear it I think it was Thomas and Alito
said they would and I was kind of
shocked by this not really but they
should have heard the case Texas has a
right to make their argument as a state
in the Union I thought they should have
heard the case too yeah it's like
if there is a question about the
procedure by which a vote a procedure by
which which votes are cast and one of
the states says that what Texas
basically said is that Pennsylvania is
negating our votes by holding their
election in such a way that violates the
U.S Constitution right they also said
that the Pennsylvania was holding their
election in a way that I think violated
Pennsylvania law right and then which
was the violation yeah but then
ultimately I think the Pennsylvania
Supreme Court said no it's fine which is
just the whole thing's still contested
no one's satisfied with the results but
my point is not to say that anyone's
right or wrong in that whole argument
I'm we can have an argument about that
later my point is when you have almost
half the country suing the other half
like is that not indicative of something
really crazy happening in this country
then you get January 6 then you get you
know I think Aaron Rodgers was killed
before January 6 right it was was it
2020 I think Aaron Rodgers is the
football yeah
I know there's a lot of shoes
Daniels was the Daniels versus Summer of
2020. yeah wasn't he yeah Aaron Daniel
said right yeah yeah
um so you had you had that you have that
happen and then you get January 6th now
you you have a bunch of these stories in
Provo Utah they ran up to a BLM ran up
to a a random person and shot him in
their car that's a random person there
was nothing in Denver what was it what
was the thing in Denver the thing in
Denver there was a guy who had been sort
of hired as a security guard but had
never been vetted and shot a
conservative activists yeah and then
after all of that what I think happens
is you're a frog in a pot and the
water's boiling and so then you see
people be like you know what I went
outside and nothing's happening and it's
like do you have amnesia did you forget
everything that happened in the past
couple of years that's going to be in
the history books people do forget
everything right people forget
everything except what happens right
around when they're currently thinking
about everything you know they don't
think about what happened before
um everyone wants you to forget about
what happened in 2020 everyone wants you
to forget about covid they don't want
you to remember that your kids got sent
home from school that your kids are like
doing math at some grade level well
below their current age they don't want
you to think about any of that they're
just like that's over we're moving on
you know someone in the chat said crime
is not Civil War and I'm not saying it
is I'm saying that Bleeding Kansas also
wasn't Civil War but people were
fighting over the issue of slavery and
if we're now dealing with a story where
an old woman was shot in the back
because she was arguing about you know
being opposed to abortion many people
have argued that abortion could be the
moral Catalyst for us well you said that
yourself yeah yeah I've said it but but
many other smarter people than me have
have made a similar point I think
um who was it was the guardian published
an article about it might have been and
um I don't want I don't want to say the
wrong person so I'll avoid but it was
like a prominent leftist who said they
thought that abortion would be a would
be a candlest of Civil War not unlike
slavery yeah and so so now you have with
this is this is interesting with Lindsey
Graham pushing for a National 15-week
Abortion ban which only really helps the
Democrats but imagine if it has no
impact imagine if Republicans still win
and according to conservative brief win
better than anyone expected the left is
gonna be like okay now they're gonna
nationally ban abortion yo someone just
got shot for being pro-life what do you
think is going to happen if the
Republicans win in the midterms Joe
Biden will say I'll veto it
Trump will then say if you elect me in
2024 the first thing I will sign is the
15-week abortion ban right and then
they're going to be screaming and
smashing everything which will only make
their chances of winning worse I think
it should be a state's rights issue I
think yeah I agree I think it should
stay there it is a States right it is a
state's right to rights issue yeah
that's right and it's amazing and now
we're moving back into an era of
potential Civil War where there's a
states rights issue right around the
right to life always it's always a
state's rights issue yeah that's always
uh that's something that we come up
against Affairs everything should be a
state starts this year everything should
be disappeared with everything
everything they do have a constitution
so a lot of stuff isn't but for for uh
someone like Sheamus for instance he
thinks it should be banned federally
because it's murder I'm sure most
conservatives probably think actually
it's murder and it shouldn't be allowed
and then the more like
governmentally conservative libertarian
types are like let the states decide but
on the moral question conservatives
outright are like no murder shouldn't be
allowed period so we're moving into this
similar territory to the first Civil War
I called the first Civil War 20. where
it's like the nation should ban the
murder of babies and unborn babies are
humans with unique DNA and and should
have a right should have protections
under the Constitution well that one
thing was fascinating one side is saying
no to that all right so so you saw you
saw they change the definition of a
heartbeat they changed the definition of
heartbeat and you know why they did they
did because of to back Stacey Abrams
they no they changed it before she said
that oh really Planned Parenthood
changed the definition of of heartbeat
uh they said that it's not a heartbeat
it's cardiac activity at six weeks well
they were saying that in 2017 as well
yeah yeah and the reason they did this
is because the heartbeat bills that are
being passed right so yeah they did that
in 2017 in the Atlantic and then in 2021
definition well they started talking
about what cardiac activity actually
means and then golden Parenthood did
blogs about it in 2021. they pass a law
that says once a heartbeat is detected
you can't get an abortion they're gonna
oh the media comes out and says not
heartbeat well that's you know that's
what it's been with so many things you
know I feel like we should have a
running glossary of words that have been
changed to suit the Biden Administration
from heartbeat to recession uh to
vaccine efficacy you know like all of
these various things
um we used to know what the words mean
can just mean something different if
people in charge want it to well they
just change they get they get a bunch of
people to back it and then when you're
standing over here standing literally on
the word which reminds me of that old
gospel song from the 70s
um when you're over here standing on the
word and they're telling you the words
that you're standing on have now been
altered to suit their own political
machinations you know to suit their
their political needs it's a very
disconcerting to look at it and you know
and say like I thought this word mean X
and now it means something else to
everybody else I've got to give people
some good news though okay we can't all
just wallow in self-pity and fear the
New York Post reports Nancy Pelosi booed
in guest appearance at New York City's
Global citizen Music Festival I think
though Tim the part that you're missing
is where they're about to change the
word the meaning of the word booze
that's right that's to me and it's
really really loved it everybody knows
boo means to show enthusiasm
so Nancy Pelosi comes out they were all
saying Nancy Pelosi comes out on stage
and the the liberal stronghold of New
York City and The Crowd Goes Nuts
screaming the video is hilarious because
a guy's like it's Nancy Pelosi why is
everybody booing seriously
oh yeah but the best part was like you
can hear some of the women booing it's
very high pitched like boom and I'm like
everyone is the boo you can really hear
the tones here yeah now this is good
news look it's because this should be
kind of a white pill in that everybody
hates Nancy Pelosi so at least there's
that like what if everything ends with
the left and the right holding hands and
singing about how much they hate Chuck
Schumer Pelosi Nadler yeah I think that
people really dislike oligarchy and
oligarchs in control of our government
it's not even who it's if an oligarch
gets in or someone gets in there and
then becomes an oligarch like she's been
well allegedly making all sorts of money
off stock trades I've never seen the
data to prove it but this is what I've
heard we don't want people like I don't
want people like that in charge they're
going to sell country she makes better
stocks trades than Warren Buffett than
anyone else in the world how can you not
see it it's like it's like the right in
front of my face it's right in front of
your face and and seeing this video has
honestly restored my faith in humanity
seeing it and and then there's there's
an amazing photo of of her co-host that
went up on stage with her being like hey
here's Nancy and Nancy's kind of
standing there like holy cow what did I
just get myself into getting a reality
call as she's trying to push a climate
change agenda and then everyone is just
not having it so so seeing this
absolutely shows you that that there is
absolutely they're huge huge huge are
you lowering my volume no what about
touching it unpopularly huge and I'm
distracted by the huge ginormous
unpopularity when it comes to the
current political establishment and it's
something that I think we need to focus
on and talk about more because the
reality probably is a lot different than
what we're getting on big Tech social
media that that manipulates the
algorithm here's here's what we'll do we
will we will uh create an event called
the we hate Nancy Pelosi Festival right
because you see hate you said hate was a
bad thing so yeah you guys are saying
but I'm saying right now if everyone in
the country hates Nancy Pelosi well then
it could be unifying right exactly we
could really all come together
84 so we should we should legit do a
skip we got to do a skit where it's like
a guy in a Maga hat and a guy with like
a pride flag and they're yelling at each
other and then it's like oh you're nuts
you support Nancy Pelosi another guy
goes what I hate Nancy Pelosi and then
the Trump guy goes you hate Nancy Pelosi
too yes I despise her really me too
really yeah what about her don't you
like oh she's a corporate show I know
really
sit down for a second and they sit down
and they're drinking together and they
become best friends and buddies for the
rest of their lives and they die old you
remember her covert haircut
freezer packed with ice cream
Sean that was so toned it was
unbelievable it was the capital city of
The Hunger yes everyone being like my
life is ruined she's like look at my 20
ice cream you're like no no I can't work
120 I can't pay the bills she had entire
freezer full it's like packed she
couldn't even fit her like emergency
Chicken in there or whatever like a
thousand dollars worth of ice cream in
her friends oh my goodness that was so
horrible and Biden was like I love ice
cream too
this is a the Democratic party
represents like it's a capital city and
then the corporate media Trump had two
scoops of ice cream he's bad right and
Biden's out there like with a dripping
off his chin I don't know do you think
term limits would solve it like flat out
solve this problem of oligarchs I don't
think so
the the issue isn't oligarchs the issue
is culture that people would vote for
Nancy Pelosi I know but like what are
they voting for actually just the name I
mean they might I mean yes to a certain
extent I mean people are you guys are
Outsourcing their political views to
whatever seems most expedient I don't
think they're voting for her I think
they're going and voting Democrat right
that's why I was saying a long time ago
remove Democrat republican from the from
the ballot so you don't know what party
they're a part of also first names just
initials so you can't tell who's who at
all what that would be interesting if
you have no idea who you're voting for
people go in and they go Democrat
Democrat democrat or republican
Republican Republican no if you don't
know who you're voting for don't vote
for them right that makes it so remove
the party in just the names and then and
then you'll be looking at a bunch of
names and like I don't know but that's
what people do is they just like they
know they see the Democrat and they've
been in Pennsylvania they had a thing
for a while where you could just click
Democrat and give all you can pull the
lever you could just pull the I had a
politics teacher in high school uh Pat
rice Snyder and she talked about that
just pull the lever yeah
away at the top
I never voted in Pennsylvania I only
ever voted in New York so I say we
remove parties from the ballot so you'll
just see names what about for the
primary all well for the primary you
don't need to party on it anyway it's
the it's it's just like that should be
open I think do you think we've talked
about this before open primaries are
terrible I've been thinking about it
back and forth
yeah what is your thought uh I've been
wondering about it because in New York
I'm registered I'm a registered Democrat
so that I can vote in the primary that
has the most say over who ends up on the
final ballot
um but then I can't vote in the
Republican primary which would be where
I could vote for who I think should
probably actually be in charge well then
you should register as a republican yeah
but then you don't have a say in the
other side so it's kind of like the
problem is when Democrats and open
primaries sabotage or Republicans could
do the same thing so that's not a good
idea right so pull off the dndr term
limits two terms and we gotta have open
source voting machines because that's my
most demoralized issues
yeah I can't stand like 10 term 85 year
olds that are like dripping I mean I
would say Ron two terms and out if I
could get the other 80 people afforded
term limits so exactly he's a guy that
would give up the power out of
righteousness
I think the issue with term limits is
you just create an industry that is a
shadow industry where people will form
committees to choose who's going to be
the next person they have to keep
picking and choosing somebody but but at
least the new person won't figure out
the swamp fast enough in order to of
course sell everyone down the river
except that they'll have all the
connections already pre-set up but they
already have the connections
term limits for staffers too you need
term limits for everybody turn limits or
FBI agents CIA agency work one year
you're out goodbye for about one year no
no no no one year one month
this is absolutely insane the FBI should
be walked in the door they get a one
hour explanation for why what they do is
bad and then they're fired right away
exactly I like that
mine was kind of a a a one year well
yeah one year and then you get someone
new in there and then one year and you
get someone and then before you're
training and figure it out they're all
out when you get hired as an IRS agent
they walk you in and you listen to a
seminar and why taxation is theft and
then they fire you yeah yeah absolutely
no one will do this I'm open to it I'm
open to term limits but I I really we
need open source voting machines I can't
handle the the private proprietary
voting machines anymore that's the most
demoralizing yeah that's crazy to think
that I go in and I cast my vote and then
it goes to a machine that it's tallied
and private and no one can see the code
so you don't know if it's actually
tallying it accurately like that just it
tears me down and makes me like not that
I don't want to vote but like I'm I'm I
feel hopeless did you vote in 2020. no
you didn't no no okay well then yeah I
just told people to vote for her
well I was going to say I wasn't
registered at the time I just moved so
vote so make sure you're registered now
vote in this election and then if it
turns out the place in which you vote
uses proprietary voting machines you can
file a lawsuit because you'll have
standing and you'll say I want to see
the code because for all I know it's a
random number generator
then you'll win someone's withstanding
just needs to do it so I guess if for
that matter I'm not a lawyer so I don't
necessarily know for sure but I'd
imagine if you did vote you should have
a right as a member of the public to see
the code to know how the machine works I
was told the story a long time ago to
Chicago where a guy I got got a speeding
ticket
and he subpoenaed the code for the radar
gun and he told the judge for all I know
it's a random number generator he the
you have to prove it's interesting you
have to prove to the court it actually
tracks your speed and how it how it's
done and and the the company apparently
was like this is proprietary and you you
can't have it and they were like no it's
used in the public and it never impact
people's lives and so he actually got it
released and then I think he had to pay
the ticket or something okay so it
wasn't random it was not a random number
generator no it actually works yeah okay
yep uses radar you know bounces I always
check that when I'm like driving by
something that has your speed thing on
it and it's not always right
yeah but I mean I don't know where the
camera is or whatever but that's the
point right how do we know any of these
voting machines do what they say they do
unless the code is released to the
public so if you voted and you're
concerned just you file a lawsuit as per
the Public's right to know what these
machines do and how they do it it's
interesting because it you know having
it be proprietary and third party seems
messed up but also having an entire
government agency dedicated to creating
voting machines would seem messed up
so maybe we should just have paper
ballots account them geez that's even
more I feel like that's even more messed
up everybody hands their box to a guy
who goes into a back room's like yeah
it's uh 74-31 they count them they count
them in yeah where Everyone's Watching
on camera yeah I kind of like that okay
how many is that like ten thousand hours
of footage that no one no one person oh
someone's gonna watch it what do you
think you're gonna do just watch it like
just live stream it I mean watch it all
over the world like if someone's
standing at a computer and then there's
50 people behind them and they made
people stand far away to watch too this
last time right what was it Arizona if
they push a button on the computer how
do you know that they're that they're
doing it accurately you don't exactly so
it's like you know what we're doing what
they're doing they write down the number
and then hand the sheet to to someone
else well we're coming up again
right I mean at a certain point we have
to be able to trust each other or have
trustless systems I think it's better
what is it what would a trustless system
even look like I just really think it
gets pushed and then Vitality happens
and you see all the math it's going to
be a lot easier for everyone just to
pick their their warlord and just to
have a suggestion box for the warlord
exactly
I'd like my dictator tonight
and then say no next exactly and they'll
be better off probably than what we have
right now in my opinion well like with
crypto I can't like send you data and
then you don't get it like I you get it
or I know yeah it goes so like no
they're talking about they're talking
about doing crypto based voting in
Africa and I think some local
jurisdictions have already implemented
it where everything is on the blockchain
people are able to see the receipts
people are able to see everything coming
back moving back and forward and um
that's that I was at a African Bitcoin
conference in Nigeria that was actually
implementing this in local regions so
there is a possibility of implementing
this kind of Open Source free technology
with all the receipts all the
transactions with the public blockchain
that I think would be worth looking into
uh but essentially with how corrupted
our political system my suggestion boxes
almost the same in my opinion let's talk
about the future of this country it is
often said that California is about five
years ahead of the rest of the country
nationally well I give you this story
from the Hill California first state to
ban natural gas heaters and furnaces
quote while this strategy will clean the
air for all Californians it will also
lead to reduced emissions in the many
low-income and disadvantaged communities
that experience greater levels of
persistent air pollution ah it's for the
poor people that you can't have heat
anymore okay poor people don't need heat
yeah no right yeah I mean yeah poverty
generates energy right and they're just
naturally warm you know plus I think
they probably already have tools they
can create fire this always this kind of
stuff always reminds me of um
I always forget to what play it is
anyway it's uh it's Chekhov and then
three sisters what's his name I have it
right Anton Chekhov yeah and he's saying
uh he's saying ah it's Uncle Vanya it's
Uncle Vanya it's Uncle Vanya and he's
talking about the trees and why do the
peasants always burn down the trees
you know and he's like why is this why
the peasants need to burn down the trees
can't they just use peat they can pick
it up off the ground and burn that and
of course burning peat is a much dirtier
um it's a much dirtier Source the smoke
is worse and all of that
um but we're constantly trying to tell
everybody how they need to
Heat their homes how they need to you
know move around all of this so that's
unreasonable they ban gas cars they're
banning natural gas heaters so
everything's going to be electric
everything's going to be electric it's
going to collect but first it's already
it already is collapsing and then
already I mean you saw this we talked
about this and uh then they tell you
that you can't charge your cars right so
it's all it what what the end result is
is going to be controlling your
movements the controls what it really is
is artificial scarcity this is done in
order to control populations as you're
limiting energy you limit also almost
everything else in someone's life in
society you're also able to limit their
food their travel and their progression
and any kind of upward economic Mobility
has been robbed and Stripped Away from
the average American as of course we're
all told that we're doing it for the
right causes we're doing it as the
people literally causing the most amount
of pollution in this world are are
flying around in their private jets and
and swimming around in their yachts and
living in their Mansions why aren't they
restricted if this was really truly
about helping the environment maybe the
over consumers maybe the richest people
in this world maybe the people who have
way too much would have been dealt with
in a truly communistic kind of system if
we're going by their rules and laws but
we're not doing any of that are
punishing the poorest people and
creating some of the poorest people in
this world and what this is is exactly
artificial scarcity to predominantly
bring in more controls by governments
that want to run every aspect of your
life but because of the Teslas have cell
connectivity and it's going to be funny
in what five years when you're going to
be in your garage and there's going to
be a notice saying not charging on your
Tesla or electric car you're gonna sit
down and you're gonna be like I only
have 30 battery I can't go anywhere and
it's like Governor's orders emergency
grid lockdown your bet your part your
car's not charging so then what people
will do is they're going to get Faraday
cages you're going to try and like
airplane mode you can't airplane mode
the car the car always have the
connectivity so people will be like oh
build the Faraday cage so the internet
can't tell it what to do you're going to
go in your car and it's going to be like
no connectivity can't charge it's going
to connect to the internet to charge
your vehicle yeah that's going to do
that yep and it's just going to keep you
where you are and then they're going to
tell you what food that you can eat and
everything yes
you're going to get in your car it's
going to be charged and you're going to
punch in the address for your work
you're going to pull out get under the
road and then all of a sudden it's going
to turn the lights in the car will turn
red and then the car will just start
driving and it'll be like Warren warrant
submitted for Ian Crossland driving to
fifth Precinct and you're gonna go what
and it's like warrant for excessive
energy use orange juice you're just
going to say that you can go to work and
you can't go anywhere else
it'll drive you to the police completely
antithetical to the United States the
Constitution of freedom of property
freedom of speech freedom of action like
I don't know that's why they're trying
to get rid of it it's just just makes I
mean the god of the government's got to
understand that essentially trying to
essentially plan people's lives is not
good the Soviet Union did that and
collapsed but they think they're doing
it for altruistic reasons they think
they're doing it to help us
no one accuses do you think that
overpopulation is actually a threat yes
I don't think I don't think it is the
science and data prove it's not like
overpopulation of deer for instance
aren't we below replacement rate right
now yes
the issue is the density of cities so
but that was okay but the density of
cities was already part of the
sustainable movement was to like get
more people into cities that's a
terrible idea because it creates it
generates massive waste that can't be
washed away but it also I mean there are
ways to there are these like living
machines have you guys heard about this
that like it's like they're not they're
not pods bugs no it's not bugs it's like
an entire Flora system that it's not a
composting toilet it's like the next
step from a composting toilet it's like
The Next Step Up
anyway it's a toilet it's not a toilet
it's a whole system it's a living
machine and it takes all of the waste
and it turns it into like a big Garden
kind of thing and you can put these in
apartment buildings that you turn into
cities so you have like massive
apartment building cities that have zero
um carbon footprint they produce no
waste because it's all goes through
these living machines anyway it does
this whole thing but so my point is if
massive growth of cities which to a
certain extent is part of a sustainable
idea
is a failure as well
why isn't it apparent that like we
haven't come up with the right idea yet
right so why are we continuously
enforcing these ideas that have not been
proven out
we need to live like they lived in
Avatar you know
live under trees and hold hands and rock
back and forth oh right but I think that
they're afraid of zoonotic disease or
the humans are disturbed because they
have in one way they're like cities are
grossly overpopulated but secondly
they're like we need people in mega
cities because we don't want them to
disrupt that is like the 2050 City
remember that the like 2050 city was a
thing before the 2035 no car thing
they're continuously coming up with
these ideas so like they're afraid that
humans are going to poison the Earth so
instead they're going to try and force
them into large cities that are
poisonous to the Earth yes a lot of the
policies that you're seeing done in the
name of climate change are creating more
climate change especially when it comes
to you know limiting energy shooting uh
you know down nuclear reactors getting
rid of of you know energy that could be
explored that could be produced there's
there's been domestic policies in Europe
in the United States that deliberately
hinder energy to the people energy is
correlated to economic prosperity and
and this is to me done deliberately
people call it the great reset people
call it the great collapse I think there
are far larger consequences to this than
than the average person even kind of
understands or could even comprehend
here so so if you look at a lot of these
policies a lot of them are correlated
with more pollution more disastrous uh
you know situations for the poorest
people in the world
I was thinking of that wall the wall and
that where Saudi Arabia or UAE somewhere
they want to build this large city oh
the line the line yeah the line and
maybe nonsense they're thinking that
it's defensible if chaos were to erupt
on Earth and there was a global war that
the large cities mega cities we could
defend them with air support we know
where everyone is and chaos is dangerous
but like the realistic thing is if
everything's concentrated in one area
then it's a bombing Target it also seems
really disgusting and horrible like
you'd be trapped because it would be a
walled City like that's that's such
regression we used to have like Paris
was a walled City you know I don't think
we need a walled City yeah you can't go
outside you can't be free you can't
escape the prison that they're literally
building for you and in in many cities
there's already but only poor people
yeah exactly yeah because everybody else
has their own way Lauren and and Zach
and and they're gonna have their Jacobs
they're going to have their Elysium in
the sky they're gonna have their private
island up in the sky it feels like this
technocratic obsession with order is
like a video game like they think it's
gonna work like a video game but people
are chaotic by Nature they are chaotic
and that's that's how we are that's how
humans and monkeys have always been we
rip and tear and grow and die and so I
don't understand what these what these
videos are are intending what the what
this technological generation
of the people they want there to be 500
million people and so they are working
towards making less people these are
also the same people though that would
have you believe that Native Americans
were peaceful and didn't you know they
would like infantilize indigenous
populations and say that they had no
none of the kind of impulses that modern
man has
you know that's crazy too
yeah we were talking about that a couple
days ago on the show uh I think I think
we had a interesting conversation about
that as well there's there's a lot of
things that we don't know especially
when it comes to history I think you
know if you think the news is fake wait
until you find out about history and uh
you know you you really examine who's
telling us these kind of narratives you
kind of have to ask yourself why are we
being told these specific things why is
this being reiterated to us and at the
end of the day I think it's a lot of it
is to weaken the human Spirit the human
will and I think largely you know trying
to understand it I I I think it's
difficult for many people because it's
impossible to get into the mind of
someone who might be a sociopath or
someone who truly is a part of maybe a
larger energetic demonic world out there
so there's all potentials out here it's
not worth speculating but it is worth
documenting the the the things that they
do and the effects that they have on
humanity and you cannot argue that
within the last three years all the
centralized policies have wrecked havoc
on the average average human being we
have destroyed our way of life we have
destroyed our physical health our mental
health our intelligence our our ability
to have family members to procreate and
live life here on this human Planet
we've destroyed all of that because we
have given authority to the government
and I think the more that the government
exists the more that they do the more
that the average human being lives in
Havoc the less government does the less
Havoc we have and I think this is why
you know one of the answers is
decentralization I mean I think in a lot
of cases everything that you're saying
about you know how we did that
um I think a lot of it was not people
giving the authority but having the
authority taken and us just looking at
it like oh my goodness they're they're
doing this they're taking this I think
that we were relatively complacent about
the luxury of our lifestyles about our
ability to move and exist freely say
what we think you know have seek the
medical treatment that we think is
appropriate all of this and I think that
a lot of us I know that I was
um despite everything sort of shocked to
see how the government just came in and
obliterated our rights and just
completely took them away started lying
to us about everything right I mean if
we've we've talked about this you know
like stay in your homes don't go to work
you're you're massively germy except if
you're protesting black Trans lives in
front of the Brooklyn Museum then it's
fine and it was just so shocking to be
lied to consistently and to be told that
those lies were truth and you're just
standing there with your mouth wide open
in shock to be told this after here you
thought you were in a democratic system
with
um good values where we all agreed on
the Bill of Rights and then just to have
it squashed I mean I don't think that we
necessarily gave the authority to do all
of this to the government I think it was
taken and we were stunned because we
didn't expect it and I think you can
look at that in a number of areas of
American life including education so I
talked to a lot of people who are
education activists particularly
conservatives and parents who realized
only during you know we only really
realized during the pandemic when school
came home and it turned out to be trash
what was being done to our kids you know
that this indoctrination was already in
there it had been in there for years it
wasn't new it was it the only reason
it's in the news now is because it has
been realized so people trusted all of
these systems we trusted our
institutions we trusted our you know
government to a large degree
only to find out that they were
deceiving us
successfully and then the people that
sat by and said nothing or did nothing
while it happened or I think Martin
Luther King would say was it that the
the evil will come from the men that see
evil and do nothing right or say nothing
I had some we quote like that right A
lot of people just went along with it
all that is required for evil to try
them is that good men do nothing right
yeah and so and if you don't even see it
if you don't see it happening
you know if it has been so sick if that
evil has been so successfully obfuscated
then you're just stunned when you when
you realize that it's admin all around
you that makes sense yeah the term
expert that that is a way to obfuscate
evil for sure because if you tell or
tell someone that an expert is claimed
or an expert's here now appeal to
Authority yeah I generally want to
listen to people that are experts at
what they do but it doesn't mean that
they're right right
and the siloing of information I think
was a problem you when you go to school
um it used to be when you go to school
you could become a generalist you know
the idea was that you would know a
little bit about everything and this was
a good thing and now they're still you
know they're like oh career classes in
middle school and it's like you don't
need that yeah the last thing you need
is a career class what you need is an
art class and a science class and like
and like what doctors need is a health
class as well like like a food a food
health class and a medicine Healthcare
I just want to add to your point here
because you talked about a little bit of
the censorship and I do believe if it
wasn't for the censorship the lockdowns
the mandates the Ridiculousness the
punishing of individuals would have not
lasted as long as it has but because of
the centralization of our information
and our thoughts through big Tech social
media algorithms I think it was the only
reason why they were able to get away
with so much atrocities with so much
bullcrap against the average human being
so so I just wanted to kind of uh talk
about that point that you made and and
and point it out as one of the biggest
factors to why humanity went along with
this lunacy because they didn't know
that there was another alternative
another option or that the science was
even debated or talked about I think
that's exactly right they called it
misinformation they would ban you censor
you get you fired doctors literally get
you fired you know from your job
suddenly you can't feed your family we
see this all over the place
it's and I think it was shocking to a
certain extent
um
I mean it's good that we're aware of it
now the question it I mean the price we
paid is huge the real question that we
need to be asked that nobody wants to
ask is are the people running these
programs people
or are they aliens that's right my son
was asking me that the other day he's
like Mom what if we're the aliens and I
was like that's panspermia what if
aliens what what if we started the seti
project we send out was it Voyager with
that golden desk is that what had it I
think yeah yeah the record the record on
it what if aliens found it and they were
like these people are so dumb and then
they came here and they were like we're
in control now what if they found it and
they were like these people are so
intelligent we just can't possibly go to
that quadrant yeah yeah people are
definitely afraid of the unknown and if
you can't see what the virus then that's
a way to scare people like if you see
the lion charging through the city you
at least know what to fear and if the
lion gets killed everyone knows the
Danger's over but if you can't see it I
mean if aliens want to get us they'll be
like LOL let's give them an invisible
threat it just feels like everything we
saw over the lockdowns was like a test
can't will people like will will you
pull up into a parking lot and inject a
foreign substance into your arm from a
stranger now like I understand that you
trust the people on the TV box when he
says go to your local 7-Eleven parking
lot but I kept telling people like
please don't do that please go to a
doctor because like we don't want to
normalize a culture of like walking up
to a random person and being like yes
inject me with that I want to go to a
doctor ask the doctor let them figure
out and not in doctors aren't always
right or whatever but the point is like
you're safest there as opposed to the
guy at the 7-Eleven this is not a dead
show don't just take what the man offers
you isn't that crazy though I feel like
you know taking crazy pills Ian's
confused well I'm thinking like wait
isn't it if you go to a duty injects you
he's drugging you maybe they don't use
that phrase because the guy might be
considered a doctor and it's supposed to
be a healthy thing he's putting on but
it's still he's still drugging you with
a drug that could be good for you you
don't know look you get a prescription
from a doctor you go to the doctor like
this is how some people go to your
doctor say like here's my history here's
my risk factors and let them tell you
what's right or not you don't want to
like imagine I'll tell you this let's
say I love using the plumbing analogy
let's say your toilet bursts like just
just crap everywhere there and it's a
mess and there's water spreading all
over the place and then bits are
floating on the floor
is good so imagine you decide I gotta
get this fixed so you pull into a
7-Eleven parking lot where there's a
random guy and you say hey come fix my
toilet perfect is that that makes no
sense no you call a plumber but you
might be before you do you have a
plunger so he must have been good at
what he did because he had a plunger
because he had a plunger that's why it's
just we we normalize this and it's just
absolutely insane to me that they were
people but look I'll I'll slow down it
feels like
at the very least we collected some
great data yeah people are willing to
drive up to a random parking lot in a
place they've not been and let a strange
person inject them with a foreign
to get a vaccine by your job you could
call your doctor right and say Here's my
age here's my risk factors tell me what
to do doc that I think is acceptable but
in any circumstance walk into a parking
lot and being like howdy stranger right
here that's nuts that is crazy the last
20 years has been like the The Awakening
of the American people this great red
pilling where we're seeing some people
haven't woken up yet or maybe never will
but a lot of people covet had to happen
to them they had to be smacked down by
authoritarian nightmare to realize what
an authoritarian nightmare is some
people saw the data in 2007 and were
like whoa there weren't weapons of mass
destruction in Iraq holy crap why are we
still in Afghanistan in 2011 what's this
trans-pacific partnership what's this
investor State dispute settlement that
wants to sell us out to Malaysian oil
companies this what's this
corporatization nation of the world and
there they woke up and they're alive
they're talking about it but a lot of
people are still in that process and a
lot of those people got the jab without
questioning it I just want to point out
that once we reach two thousand dollars
in super chats Luke is going to down
this whole tube hell no
no
no all right all right Libby will down
this whole nobody wants to
it's not that bad it's palm oil but it's
not buttercream it's sugar
there's like a pint I think we have like
a quart of icing right here with these
two things but you have to make those
gingerbread castles with them yeah
somebody sent us these gingerbread boxes
like two years ago and they're expired
and I cracked them open and those icings
were in it and I was like all right
who's gonna slam one of these on the
show
gingerbread houses that's what you have
to do yeah use it as glue or something
do you eat gingerbread house like you're
supposed to actually eat them no you're
desperate yeah
think about that as an American like I
used excess food to make a structure
that I'm not going to eat it's just for
decoration it's a food structure that's
so weird I don't like food structure all
right let's let's so now that we've done
a weird a weird break in the hard
politics we're gonna segue to this story
from Yahoo entertainment Alec Baldwin
May soon be criminally charged in Rust
shooting new letter shows we got them we
got it boys finally got them
I can't believe how long it's been I was
worried he was going to get away with it
I heard he was like locking up his house
and everything his 29 million dollars oh
my goodness didn't he just have a baby
didn't his wife keep getting away with
it apparently and it is the shooting of
God Rest her soul Helena Hutchins yes
who lost her life on set after Alex
accidentally
yeah
what's his name Alec Baldwin
inadvertently we should say allegedly
inadvertently look at this fired uh
bullet D.A Mary karmic altwise filed an
emergency request for 635 500 fund five
thousand funds she says are necessary to
prosecute up to four people in
connection with the accident the LA
Times obtained a letter in which karmic
altwese lays out her office is
considering homicide charges as well as
gun violations so we don't know for sure
who those people are but come on why
would it not be Alec Baldwin homeboy is
gonna get criminally charged we'll see
what happens they're gonna give him a
slap on the rest still but a homicide
charge my favorite uh we covered the
story today
um Josh Young wrote it for us my
favorite part was when he said it says
no no Baldwin said I would never point a
gun and pull the pull that trigger at
them never in August an FBI analysis
concluded that Alec Baldwin pulled the
trigger of the gun that killed
cinematographer yeah I think it's a
obviously he pulled this trigger
obviously he did this thing whether he
intended to do it or not and then you
saw the there's the video of him from
set talking about
um or showing like how he pulls the gun
out and he said he didn't have his
finger on the trigger and he does have
this finger on the trigger he lied yeah
he did he lied he shot that lady and I
think he can't handle it I think he
can't handle that he did this thing I I
said it way back when and I'll say it
again but I think he probably did it The
Simple Solution is that he intentionally
killed this woman in the conspiracy
theory is that this weird final
destination-esque thing occurred where
he accidentally shot and killed her like
the crazy thing to me about the whole
story is that let's say the wrong person
had the gun and then real bullets were
accidentally put in it Alec Baldwin
still would have had to have pulled the
trigger while pointing it at her yeah
and so it's like you can believe this
thing happened where like the gun is
like on the table and then someone like
slams a door and it falls down lands
perfectly upright and the the the
whatever it's called the revolver the
wheel comes out and then bolts roll and
fall and Landing it perfectly and then
it rolls over and closes and then
someone picks up and puts it back on the
counter and then they open it and then
hand it out like all those weird things
could have happened I guess anything
crazy will happen yeah like Baldwin just
killed a lady that he was presumably
seems more likely fighting with over
what was going on in the set I think
someone hated Alec and loaded that gun
behind everybody's back and then they
just because they were so negligent on
set no one checked it and then he went
he was play toying like he was an 11
year old kid like I want to kill oh and
he's like fantasizing about killing her
with an empty gun and then there's
actually a bullet so so here's the thing
pretty good the issue with that is that
it requires you to make up a
circumstance that's yeah for sure
my scenario is that Alec Baldwin was
seen in a meeting with her he was seen
having dinner with her they were not
friends he called her very aggressive
and intense in a previous interview
there were problems on set those things
are facts do you think he meant to kill
her yes what I think is that the most
likely outcome maybe it's only five
percent but you know for Ian's point
that someone secretly loaded the gun
you're making up why there's no evidence
and no circumstance to support why
someone would do that the motive would
be that they hated Alec Baldwin because
he was such a horrible producer and the
set was so grueling people were unhappy
I don't think they knew what was gonna
happen they were going to frame him for
murder basically see the problem with
that is you're saying the crew was angry
that we know so they put a real bullet
in his gun but that would end up
enduring not Alec Baldwin so it's like
perhaps you can assume the person who
would have done that was Reckless and
also didn't care that they would kill an
innocent person I think that's a bigger
leap than Alec Baldwin was fighting with
a woman who was a crew member and the
crew were having problems so he shot her
so Ian's Ian's version though would do
really well on something like Magnum PI
yeah that's right right yeah it will be
it will there will be a movie of the
week about this right it would be a
terrific uh it would be a terrific
mystery well so if this just Fletcher
would figure it out okay I don't know I
don't know never mind if this so if this
goes to try trial then are they going to
try and figure intent is that what this
is all about to figure out what the
depends how they charge him with
so I don't I don't know man a lot of
people were like he's an actor he was
handed the gun it's not his fault and
I'm like do you think that matters he's
an actor he's standing the gun and it is
his fault yeah as well as the producer's
fault for not overseeing the Armor's
fault yeah he's one of the like four or
five producers so all the producers
might be on the hook for this I wouldn't
be surprised if they charge the armorer
because she handed the gun the assistant
director who I think the ad actually
handed the gun to Alec and he wasn't
supposed to have his hands on that gun
well they were also struggling with
production and people were complaining
on set that the the film wasn't budgeted
correctly and a lot of the staff were
asking for a proper budget for the movie
so there was you know a lot of disputes
a lot of arguments what really happened
here I don't know only one person should
be criminally charged in a salad bowling
yeah if someone hands you a gun for any
reason and you pointed another person
pull the hammer back and then pull the
trigger or you've already got the
trigger depressed you shot that person
it's crazy to me that there's like the
Liberals are arguing the left is arguing
that because he's an actor he's in some
special privileged class and I'm like I
I don't know I don't know that makes no
sense to me I don't care if you're an
actor or not if like someone's like
we're doing a stunt and I'm gonna give
you a sledgehammer but don't actually
you know swing it at my face and then
you do it's like you hit him in the face
if they had waivers signed and it was
like Hey we're gonna be swinging
sledgehammers everyone's saying if
something happens to me then the
production's not responsible because we
don't know it's very risky and they know
the risk ahead of time and someone gets
killed that's a different story perhaps
I don't know if that's a different I
don't know that you could uh like up
your liability for getting killed do you
know what I mean like it's but it is a
fair point that Helena Hutchins knew he
would be pointing the gun at her and she
chose to be there under those
circumstances so that probably does put
it more Sim simply as it into an
accidental space like the sledgehammer
thing could work but if you're like
doing a magic trick where you're
supposed to swing a sledgehammer at
someone and they escape before you hit
them and then they get hit well in that
case like you the person with a
sledgehammer were telling them to do it
and apparently they're saying on the
film Helena Hutchins is telling Alec
Baldwin to pull the trigger oh wow well
she's like telling him at this point
yeah get the shot get the shot get the
shot and Alec is getting frustrated and
frustrated or something and then he
finally goes off and hits her I gotta
see it happening it's so crazy it's just
such a casual thing that could go wrong
which is why gun safety is so important
but that's the thing like they shouldn't
use real guns
no they shouldn't use real guns I was
working on a show Once a play and we had
a shotgun in the play and we were using
a real gun but there were no bullets on
set anywhere but it was still like super
intense
um and a big deal if you were handling
the gun you know there were like
intensive rules about if you were
handling handling the gun even though
there were no bullets anywhere you know
on set at all yeah there were supposedly
no live rounds on set for this movie too
it's whatever we didn't have like not
only no we had nothing nothing ever went
in the gun but like it we were so
careful with that thing I just want to
point this out in the Yahoo
entertainment story It Ends by saying
this more Alec Baldwin feared he would
be killed by Trump supporters over rust
shooting it's not a link I don't
politicizes what does that mean there's
no link there do a little search of that
they just what is that they just added
this to the end of the story like oh as
an aside Trump supporters were going to
kill him he thinks why would they put
that at the bottom of the story maybe he
was in the car with that guy in North
Dakota you know he was like him and that
guy are super tight apparently man did
you see that SNL is like they think it's
going to end oh let's talk about it
really well they lost eight members why
because the show's garbage they have
their first but they have their first
non-binary member so obviously it's
going to do amazing right now okay you
know what Edie what's her name is it
left the show 80 people oh really but
didn't they were like right they were
like building with 80 Bryant they really
oh they had oh yeah and a feature player
yeah too so they had eight people drop
out I don't know exactly what happened
but here's the issue
you used to have like three or four
channels what was that you'd have like
three or four channels that was good and
you you turn on the nightly the night
show whatever late night show or
whatever and then on Saturday it's SNL
everybody watched it because that was
what to watch on Saturday now you've got
a million channels you've got a million
influencers you've got all these
different videos and what's going on
what I don't know is that me not me
that's that weird noise
did you hear what are you doing anyway
the point is SNL doesn't matter anymore
because there's two there's on demand
video you can watch it anytime they
should just call it NL they should just
do sketch counts just live they should
make a YouTube channel where they
randomly just upload yeah that's exactly
what they should do now forget the
Saturday night thing it's grueling for
the actors anyway they all know it's
like boot camp that's not funny yeah
it's stretched it's like they're I don't
know I don't watch it anymore no I
haven't watched it in years and years
I've seen some real painful sketches I
think common is a genius I love the guy
rewatched more Monty Python than I've
watched yeah comedy should be free and
it should be a critique of our society
but now our our society can't be
critiqued we can't laugh at certain
ideas we can't laugh at certain hot
button issues which defeats the whole
purpose of Comedy which of course it was
kind of a a tool in society that made
things easy that that made people laugh
that that brought people together and
and I think the way that Society is is
really being pushed into this this
really negative way that that comedy
isn't allowed and SNL being off the air
and potentially losing its entire show
uh I think highlights this we used to be
able to laugh at other people's
suffering which is kind of horrible to
think of but that was like a big part of
freedom is you're allowed to make fun of
whoever you want and this moral police
of today even like in Canada like you
might even get arrested for doing it
sometimes for making people
uncomfortable or whatever just intro
dough well no no no no no no no no no if
like you make them uncomfortable by
saying naughty words perhaps but if you
make them uncomfortable by wearing big
old fake novelty side yeah now we're
talking then you're you're accepted you
could do whatever you want as soon as
you got these things on I personally
don't like making fun of other people's
pain I don't like doing it personally I
see someone do it someone else I find it
derogatory and hateful I'm like well I
don't like that but that's comedy man
that's the history of it and you know
damn be the consequences I guess maybe
but if you're able to laugh at something
difficult in life you're able to of
course turn it around for being
something so negative so a lot of the
times we deal with something very
serious we deal with that something
that's that's impacting us laughing at
it even though it might be something
that that hurts you a lot of the times
helps a lot of people deal with a lot of
the trauma in our society like covid
people lost people with coveted so if
people were making jokes about that like
oh yeah grandma in the hospital and
doing a joke like 100 years ago and then
you do the whole too soon like that's a
meme is it too soon to joke about
because it just happened but like you
couldn't I couldn't even speak out about
the science of covid while it was
happening without getting banned off of
Facebook it was crazy to figure it out
Trump should start selling search shirts
and hats that say the great reset and it
should be like with my election in 2024
I'm going to reset the establishment
we're going to change everything and go
back back to when it was great by
resetting it that way all of the elites
are forced to say the great race is a
bad thing yeah they'll be like stop with
the great reset stop it but uh Trump and
prices they'll just think of a new PR
name to brainwash everyone to go along
the the the beginning March restart the
large restart the March restart you know
the future enslavement yeah that's
another way
the you will owe nothing and be happy
just the future boots stomping on your
face it's uh totally trendy and cool you
know totally yeah
I just I never understood the bug thing
because chickens eat bugs you know what
I mean why can't you have chickens I
don't get it well I think it's also why
they're pushing for a meatless Society
why Bill Gates pushes this Peta also
just came out with a new push and call
saying that if someone eats meat you
shouldn't have relations with them that
was their latest PR campaign and if you
look at you know there there was also a
new study that the New York Post
actually talked about today uh
highlighting specifically uh people who
are vegetarian and vegan or twice as
likely to become depressed than people
who eat meat and I think you know a lot
of this is correlated and I think they
want you weak they want you fat they
want you obese they want you unhealthy
and this is a part of the larger agenda
that is really about enslaving the rest
of humanity I also really want you to
not have sex have you noticed that like
yeah
activism is against people having sex
and having kids and also Barack Obama
blow up a bunch of kids you're like
what's going on there you know I think
Sheamus nailed it when he said oh you
gotta blow up kids too many of them
vote for me yeah yeah pretty much we got
a lot of super I'm really excited to
read Klaus Schwab's book I'm going to
stop talking about I'm telling you hey
you could thank those super chats
because of me okay that's what's
correlated hey you look at the top top
chatted uh top Super chatted channels
what do they have in common we do have a
lot of super chats tonight yeah I
appreciate you the chest is looking
great you guys are welcome yeah it's a
nice shirt you gotta lift and separate
you gotta lift inside don't worry about
it
all right let's go to super chats if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
be the notification YouTube's been
giving us some Silly business and people
have been pointing out that they're not
getting notifications so it's not
surprising we're about a month out from
the midterms and we're starting to get
jammed up a little bit so if you want to
support us share the videos share the
URL post whatever you can become a
member at timcast.com we're going to
have a spicy members only show we're
going to be talking about the conspiracy
of the big tittied Ontario teacher it
may be it may be a hoax and we've got
some new information to to discuss so uh
check that out and you can follow the
show of course at timcast IRL but let's
read some super chats
all right what is this
testers says hey Ian did Big Daddy Biden
get you some Trinity pressure yet or at
least some better calf care we poor
Aussies will never see such wonderful
things yeah I think he's working on it
actually I'll see him over Thanksgiving
oh what's this this is good
we have Ian Hall he says hi YouTube
caved I got the notification today oh
amazing
Thomas Levy says is the Amazing Atheist
still due for the show I had no idea TJ
TJ
you know I I just don't I don't know
what it is but uh every time there's a
left personality they we struggle to do
booking with them it's either you know
the last thing I talked to him about was
him saying he wanted to come on the show
he had to figure it out we'll figure it
out we never figured it out so maybe
we'll we'll get him on I invited Hassan
[ __ ] on the show again he just didn't
respond uh you know it is what it is I
like TJ back in the day 2007 when I was
doing a lot of early YouTube stuff he
would he was very critical of my work
because I was stoned and you know just
talking about Consciousness like a crazy
man and he was very literal and but he
was always like righteously critical
he'd be very harsh very direct but very
honest and like he actually cared what I
thought I like I love CJ thank you hey
it's Casper says leave it to Philip de
lefto to demonize Italy pm
that's weird because Phil was very
libertarian I watched the video it
didn't seem like he was calling her far
right but it wasn't didn't seem like it
was demonizing or did you see his video
today I haven't seen his video today but
he's pretty much like CNN liked he
pretty much just regurgitates the
establishment and what they say the
corporate media agenda and narrative he
just pretty much copies and pastes it
it's like it's like he lost his his
energy for the job and he's just like
just I'm just I'm just gonna say what
the corporate media says no no I don't
think he's ever been a guy who facts
checks
grabs the news has someone write the
blurbs and then he says here's what's
being said the difference of what we do
is that you know there'll be a story
like Trump is a Russian asset and then
we'll be like okay where's that coming
from and then we'll come on the show and
be like how can that be if that's why
yeah let's look at the evidence let's
see what they're saying let's see why
they're saying it let's see if there's
any actual validity to these rumors and
let's look at the sources and I think
and and critically think no one does
that anymore and and the obvious reason
that this show is just plainly better is
that you know Philip DeFranco is is he
doesn't have the big bazangas yeah
absolutely not yet I'm watching you yeah
he's another I think he'd be great guys
he's a little plump
I would love to talk to him I love him
about the political ideas just to get a
deep dive into his head what he really
believes in what he really thinks who he
really is yeah I think the last time I
ever said anything to him was when that
uh when when Acosta tried grabbing the
mic from that White House Aid and then
the left was claiming that she jerked it
away from him and the right was claiming
that he tried to grab it or no no he was
holding the mic and she went to grab it
and then Acosta pulls his arm down like
jerking it away or whatever and the left
was saying that she tried grabbing from
him and the right was saying he tried
pulling it away from her and my attitude
was just kind of like why should it
matter either way if the aide who is the
you know the person giving out the mic
says give me the mic back and you don't
do it how is Acosta in any way anything
but the bad guy but then he like
messaged me like do you really think
that's what happened like that's the
last thing I think it may have been
something last time I saw him was it a
hotel room in San Francisco for YouTube
live in 2008 was it nine ten something
like that talked about Zelda no I think
it was Ocarina of Time
no let's read some more Dano says uh
Dano I'm not gay but Luke knows how to
sell a shirt damn right that's right
desperate times colorful Desperate
Measures that's right oh did you guys
hear that their uh Canada's ending the
travel restrictions yes I want to go so
I've got I got a handful of people from
Canada we want to invite down now do you
when is it ending
I think officially it's already over
October 1st but the U.S still has them
don't they no it's October 1st that uh
you're gonna be allowed to leave Canada
but to fly into the United States you
need a vaccine I think it's by Airline
and I don't think it's it's uh you know
being practical I will say when the last
time I was in Canada was like probably a
year ago and I needed a vaccine card to
get in but not to get out we got a super
chat here I was driving that's going to
require a Polish fact check correction
and
um and I'm hoping you I think Luke will
get it because he speaks Polish I don't
JT fire says Lucia radkowski was born
Lucia yeah so what's what's what's the
correction if I'm if I'm not mistaken
Luke well my dead name is no I'm just
what should it actually be what do you
mean yeah
your last name
hey
well I think other countries I think
other countries do that as well yeah the
a is replaced with the eye usually
that's so weird it's like two different
last names yeah that's why Russian
novels are so confusing
like right place yeah oh because they
say Ani yeah and it just should be Lucia
camera that's right
all right let's see Raymond g Stanley Jr
says Tim last couple of months I noticed
your move from not just preparing us but
towards positivity it's like you reached
out and laid your hand on the big brain
Biden bug then declared it's afraid yes
I just think there's a secret to life
and it's chickens
they're funny he's hacked it they're
just you get chickens they make more of
themselves you eat their eggs it's
amazing I had a dream that I was eating
their eggs
it's gonna fry it in the waffle griddle
thing that we got oh that's apparently
you do that with a little salt and it
just right what happens do you end up
haven't found out yet weird Pocky eggs
I tried you know that egg you think you
showed me where like you put the you put
the egg whites in and swirl it around I
tried doing that I failed what was it
what is that yeah you get the egg white
and you kind of drip it into a pan
that's like kind of hot and then it gets
solid you go like this one around you
get like and so it sweats out and then
you put the yolk on it and then you fold
it over the white parts and you've got
like a little
why wouldn't you just fry an egg well
this gives you the raw yolk I think you
can then fry the yolk if you want well
no it's like it's crispier oh it's like
crispy on all sides so it's like a fried
egg if the white part is just tomorrow
because you can dip them in like Ranch
yeah stick like a toothpick wow okay
yeah they'll be like that's I think it'd
be better with hot sauce than Ranch
personally hot sauce and Ranch maybe a
little bit compromise hot ranch sauce
yeah orange sauce that'd be good DJ Zeno
says Tim cast IRL featuring Libby Emmons
and Luke's absolutely valid and
acceptable bazungas damn right yes
says a couple weeks ago I looked at the
names of coming hurricanes I saw Ian and
said oh ish oh yeah hurricane Ian I
didn't know you're manifesting it I
think I'm like is God real that's what's
going on my head right now woken Roland
photography says Timmy P please ask Ian
to call off his hurricane
I want to disperse it and re-coagulated
over the Sahara and I was like what I
was visualizing what rain does when it
gets into the sand I saw Ian in the
backyard a couple days ago and he was
going like this oh yeah and he was
waving crystals around I was like what
are you doing with crystals that's an
interesting idea I've never meditated
with crystals in my hands before your
rain dance was too much I bought I
bought moldavite and Luke got scared I
don't want any of that why not I just
heard bad things about it because it's
from outer space what is it you've never
heard of moldavite no it's this this is
a piece of it it's volcanic it's not
volcanically it's meteoric glass yeah
that struck Moldova people will report
having entities come to them when they
have that so the magnet so a meteor hits
Moldova and then it created glass in the
impact that's cool and then I got a
couple pendants that you can wear and
Luke was like oh dude you better keep
that away from me
I slept with it on as a pendant the
Ghost came from the pendant nothing
happened we'll see that you know of that
I know of I have a normal night's sleep
my recovery was fantastic by the way
there we go
all right Murph tries DIY says Tim I'm
trying to convince my spouse into
letting our family go as the cast of
chicken City for Halloween with a
chicken party going off every time the
kids get candy others please join oh
this is so cute you have to do that and
do a video that would be amazing the
video that would be awesome that would
be so cool
horrible I love this idea
someone you may know says hello all from
Florida where we are we are awaiting the
arrival of Ian who will destroy us with
the truth of graphene you'll be okay
I was thinking of going for Halloween as
that Ontario teacher the way you
disperse weather so the clouds are
magnetic and your body also has a
magnetic field I imagine putting
positive energy into the cloud and it
kind of like when you drip oil into
water and you see it like shoot out in
different directions you can disperse uh
also you can use the sun to kind of heat
the cloud and dissipate it that way okay
but doing it without at night is kind of
confusing because it's not above you you
have to imagine it there
it's very interesting so it might be
more of a subatomic thing Joe spinella
says people should look up the Hatfield
and McCoy Feud which was basically a
civil war within the civil war with both
sides of the family's intermixed on both
sides of the actual Civil War wow
that went on for a super long time too
yeah really long time for 30 years 28
years gray Jedi Outcast says what
separates a man from a Slave
nobody knows this one ability to choose
Freedom a man chooses there you go I
like that great John Diaz have any of
you watched The Alex Jones trial it's a
kangaroo court never thought I'd see
something like this in America and it
deserves more attention yeah we were
talking about that before the show I
watched a little bit of it and when the
judge is like sitting there and they're
going like objection objection and the
prosecutors going like and then Alex is
going and then and then he's like judge
do something and judge is like I can't
even get a word in yeah the problem I
will say is the devil Alex so I think
they were treating it as hostile witness
because if he just stopped responding to
the guy and looked at the judge and
awaited her response to the objection
she would have been like all right
you're out of order to the prosecutor
but instead Alex kept going back at him
and then so she just let it go I don't I
don't understand why Alex doesn't just
say whatever he wants
he basically was like you're instructed
that you can't talk about the bankruptcy
and so like I'm gonna say it interesting
because they'll be held in contempt okay
oh like but what does that mean it's
like he's already up on charges like
what's the difference it's civil not
criminal oh that's right and so it's
just like he's trying to preserve the
company Infowars he said I was listening
on the show a couple nights ago and he
was like I mean I've been honest with my
crew if if I get screwed if all this
money's gone I gotta shut the company
down and that's everyone's out of
business I have a job so that's what
they're trying to do the problem is Alex
Jones could grab a 20 cell phone from
Walgreens and film himself ranting and
still get the same amount of traffic so
even if the company ends he's still Alex
Jones that will never never they'll
never be gone yeah but he I mean I can
see why he'd want to keep his employees
employed yeah I think he was a big
responsibility he was like part of me
considers not even going to the court
he's like so messed up right now
mentally but he's like he's got so what
if these people rely on him so he's what
if someone else started a company and
hired him to present or better yet
contracted the rights to distribute
who would do that I wonder be
interesting I don't know I'm saying like
so that they went after him because one
of his employees started a a nutrition
supplement company that resells Infowars
products and they're they're like you
know this guy who used to work for he
was selling these products and you
benefit from it and he's like I sell
them products like I don't know like are
they gonna try and go after a third
party company that's selling supplements
well they do that right they do what I
mean if you look at the people who go
after
companies for you know they go after
like advertisers they have to go after
Alex Jones on his defamation they can't
go after a random company started by
some other person but it's the kangaroo
you got to listen to ricada law talks
about it too and Robert Barnes was being
real clear about it like this is a
situation where they're attempting to
make it illegal to hurt people's
feelings because
yeah he defeat I guess he said some
stuff about some specific people but
there's other people that haven't even
been named by Alex Jones that are like
piling on this lawsuit this according to
Robert Barnes and trying to make money
off of the way they felt as a result
whether or not he put them in danger for
naming them that's a different story
I I would highly recommend watching The
Alex Jones Robert Barnes clip from a
couple days ago they were talking about
it
about it the trial about the trial yeah
Ethan Reed says hate is absolutely a
weakness emotional reactions have
nothing to do with Instinct instinct is
a is a reflex emotional responses are
more thought out that emotional
responses are more thought out that's
why we use different words to describe
emo do you mean logical responses are
more thought out
my point is you wanna you wanna behave
rationally and logically but I don't
demonize someone feeling a thing you
want to be in control of your emotions
and feelings but you know
yeah there you go
Shinobi Kenobi say sorry Ian I don't
want you in my Foxhole
I don't know hopefully we won't have to
share one brother
Andrew Lance says holy crapped him no
hatred is evil one of the few times I
may agree with Ian love thy neighbor as
thyself love your enemy defending hatred
may be the most Antichrist thing I've
ever heard
well I think people have hate within
them you're not supposed to act on hate
you're supposed to act on logic but I
don't think you should be demonized for
experiencing a feeling you know I do
need sometimes to work hate out by
expressing it and then finding out why I
was wrong or what the problem with that
expression was later in like a safe
environment so it's something we do need
to let people continue to express their
hate openly that's protected
constitutionally Group B says I noticed
Arizona green tea at my local gas
station went up 30 cents can anyone
confirm proof of inflation Ian can you
please harness your inner Energy Power
to control the pathway of the hurricane
yes
whoa Colin says wasps pollinate figs
which are the most consumed from the
planet thanks Ian for always asking the
questions I'm thinking I never knew
isn't that crunchy thing in figs wasp I
think it's seeds because I eat figs as a
snack relatively I'm pretty sure there's
wasps in face yeah there might be a dead
wasp in there so think about that next
time
yeah I'm looking it up I know I know it
requires a wasp to pollinate it I eat
lots of should you eat figs if wasps
have died inside of them here's
everything you need to know about the
Fig wasp relationship see there you go
treeshugger.com so is that the one good
thing that wasps do is they pollinate
we have pawpaw out here hillbilly banana
and it's pollinated by beetles and flies
gross but they're delicious I've never
seen a pawpaw what do they look like are
they bigger or smaller they're like well
there's varying size maybe like this bag
you get a good one squashes big seeds
and it's like if you took banana avocado
and mango and combined it that sounds
actually pretty good it's really good
how have I never heard of this fruit
they're really good is this like an
indigenous American fruit Appalachian
fruit yeah and it doesn't last very long
it's uh I believe it's hard to transport
and hard to grow is this why I've never
seen it at the grocery store yep yes but
we've probably got in the next month
we're gonna have probably five thousand
oh geez I'm gonna come down and eat one
everywhere you'll walk through the woods
and it hits you on the head wow yeah
okay it's amazing and then you you can
get them in there like when they're real
juicy you can just like break it open
amazing
figs covered in bacon bits and maple
syrup what am I looking at
yeah that's good stuff mad love to the
wasps that stuff is good appreciated
figs and bacon are really yeah Paradise
throw some balls vinegar on there that
sounds great a little maple syrup yeah
yes all right
lives says we have been in a civil war
since the summer of love our streets and
neighborhoods were under attack the
attack was physical mental and
economical
P.S Tim do a tour and start a music
label please we are we're working on it
and uh we have a call with some Big
Industry guys tomorrow we're going to be
we got a bunch of songs in the works
we've got a top secret plan with another
company I just want to tell you
uh they're so angry about the success
we've had with the music we're putting
out and it's just it's really
encouraging Salon wrote a hit piece
claiming that my music was like white
nationalism or some other nonsense that
is such garbage I'm like they're it's
the only thing nothing like that light
eyes it's nice but like it's they're so
threatened to buy it the opening
paragraph Was if you're not into
politics you may be confused why a
horrible emo song was number two on on
iTunes and then I stopped and I was like
number two on Billboard but carry on and
the point was clear they were pointing
out that many people saw this top
tracking song and didn't know anything
about me or whatever and said oh here's
a song and listen to it and it started
trending and then it hits the charts so
they have to intervene they have to be
like that song you heard fascist it
sucks it sucks it's really bad and you
hate it but the bad news for them is we
actually got a ton of Industry support
since that song came out because it did
so well basically it's this it comes to
this and this was kind of the point
industry people want to be in the top of
the charts so when they see that we put
out music that worked and we don't have
any representation or any you know any
kind of industry connections they come
to us and they're like we want to have
our name on a song that's number two so
we can help you do better and so now
they're like we're working with these
guys and they're like we're gonna do the
release so so well next time it's going
to be it's going to hit number one it's
gonna be big we're gonna we're gonna get
you on radio we're gonna get it done
right and I'm like cool yeah let's do it
so the the we were planning on releasing
a song recently like in the next week or
so but we're gonna wait because we're
gonna do a strategy meeting we didn't do
any of it right like the YouTube views
didn't count towards billboard and we
got to make sure that everything is done
properly this time
fig wasps spend their larval stage
inside of figs interesting what the
amazing then you eat them
and then you eat the WASP I'd rather
talk about music but that was just stuck
in my head
maybe if we just That's crazy dude
redacted said Trump should Rebrand Maga
to the greatest reset it's better that
one it's it's better that one that's
just grape it's better than one that's
just great and wokeism shall henceforth
be called woke Supremacy just as
oppressive but with rainbows I like woke
Supremacy and it should be like a
glitter unicorn puking rainbows yes I'm
gonna start saying woke supremacist
system you're a woke supremacist I think
that's great yeah who coined that we
should give them yeah very good all
right Raymond g Stanley Jr says guys
what are they going to do in the
mountains Cali is huge not everywhere is
sunny and beautiful imagine Colorado
stop water to them Cali may be doomed
yeah so they ban the heaters but there's
a lot of mountains in in California so
you're gonna be like how do I heat my
house and they're like oh good luck yeah
chop down trees I guess yeah I worked up
yeah I looked up the record low
temperature in California is negative 45
degrees Fahrenheit it gets cold it does
get cold in the mountains yeah yeah I
shot a movie up in Big Bear that was
frigid yeah it's really cool
all right
79 Mike Larry says plot twist the rest
of the celestial beings in the universe
refuse to make contact with us and we
are making contact contact with a fallen
race demons
so we're like the the outcasts of the
the universe this is like the poop that
landed in our ocean it was the alien
poop and then it Formed into us no no
well I guess
all right
I Kafka says Tim could it be they
overcharge him knowing the charge can't
stick just to put him on trial and then
he gets off with no charges I'm assuming
Alec Baldwin but yeah they could be like
we're charging him and then he's found
not guilty and they go oh look he was
not guilty you know what I mean does
that happen where they'll charge people
for excessive crimes they know they
can't get them for just so that they can
find him not guilty well that's a
political question but I'm assuming it's
within the realm of possibility I don't
know how often they also overcharge
sometimes so that they can bargain them
down
this is that's something that happens a
lot DA's do that they'll throw all the
charges at a person and then
um just get them on the you know last
couple or whatever
all right Joshua Renner says I've spoken
to a retired set builder he said that
these Old-Timers would use the prop guns
for actual target practice then put the
guns back for use in the movie they were
in it says Alec did the same oh yeah
what if Alec was playing around with it
yeah they said they were going out in
target shooting at night Alec was no
well no I didn't hear that Alec was but
people on the in the that were working
on the project were because that'll be
big shooting cans out back after the day
scoot says did you hear about the
massive UFO sighting in Branson Missouri
y'all hear about that no I assume Mr
Shane Cashman did Shane I hope you heard
about that one
all right we'll look into it that'll be
fun
all right Clint
torosaurus Rex says like Krusty the
Clown said it's only funny if the
schmuck has dignity
yes it makes sense otherwise it's just
sad right like yeah coming after people
who are down on their luck
oh for dark for Gallows humor yeah
someone tweet yeah
all right let's see what do we have here
in the old super chats
Carlton XL says Luke bringing a new
meaning to the milkman
yeah
no don't tell me what to do this is this
is beautiful the way it is it's natural
okay stop hating on me you know what's
funny when you're in your perceived
image of beauty that you're subjecting
me to okay get your own pair hold on is
the lifted separate thing like a normal
thing yeah that's a normal people say
that selling point what about juggling I
don't know but I was making a joke
because I've heard people say that like
on soap operas or whatever like I've
never heard that before you know on
reality TV honey you want to lift and
separate
Lydia knows what I'm talking about you
heard this phrase I've heard that yeah
all right Pelican drummer says I'm
writing a book on morality based on
evolutionary purposes of emotions hatred
is a negative State and it has as it has
a negative health effects in the long
term anger is our drive to face a threat
but is irrational if there is no threat
agreed well certainly interesting
Winston Alexander says Global citizen is
a un globalist fundraiser crowd also
booed videos of Biden Trudeau mccrone
speeches about menstrual poverty food
climate billions raised only results
shown a villager got a few chickens hey
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
that's a result that is a result that's
a result nothing but it's actually
really cool to hear they boot everybody
because it shows that you know people
aren't aren't taking this even in New
York City I assume they're probably
booing booing her because they were
Bernie Bros you know like Bernie
supporters so you're like we don't like
the corporate Democrats but it turns out
they don't like any of them so uh I'll
take it
there you go
okay what do we got here
all right let's see Aaron Neal says you
haven't mentioned the female West VA
senator who you vowed to raise heck
against oh crapado that's her name right
crapado yes Shelly more crapado sounds
familiar I thought you just I thought
you just said crap no I forgot crapado I
forgot yeah because she supported the
gun control stuff well we got a lot of
work to do here in West Virginia so
we'll we'll make sure we always uh rag
on crap oh no the crap at all was the
porta potties I was gonna buy it
Johnny on the spot oh yeah it's Capital
that's capital so the idea was to to buy
a bunch of porta potties and donate them
and they'll say uh they'll be called
Shelly more crapado boxes
we'll just we'll donate them be like you
need a porta potty here you go you know
where you want to donate those is uh the
women's March do you know that they're
doing the big fundraiser because they
need more porta potties really for the
March yeah I get uh I'm on their mailing
list oh my gosh I'm sorry yeah well you
know it's I'm on so many mailing lists I
gotta tell you but um I mean it's funny
when I open my inbox and it's uh
messages from Save America pack and the
women's March and I'm like oh hi
everybody you guys should really get
together
um but yeah the women's marches is
seeking donations for porta potties for
the women's March where are they
marching I don't know should we check CC
yeah I think right yeah I mean it'll be
DC do you think they're going to be like
chanting pro war stuff
uh they might be out there with yeah I
don't know maybe like they should get
some abortion pills in the colors of the
Ukraine flag yeah speaking of Ukraine
and Russia I was just thinking about
this I hope that we can find peace with
Russia and Ukraine and everybody else
that's involved because I think what's
happening is the Russians want see uh
Black Sea access through Crimea and they
want those two freeways to the north uh
what freeways are these oh here it is
wait it's a 242 events from Washington
DC to Los Angeles to Elkhorn Wisconsin
and Arlington Texas thousands of fierce
feminists taking the streets women's
wave is here and an ocean is coming
women's march on October 8th will
harness the power of our Collective
voices and carry our power all the way
to The Ballot Box on November 8th but
powering our March will take resources
we need buses we need hand sanitizer and
masks of course we need signs and we
need porta potties and lots of them
maybe they need some crapados yeah it
sounds like it all right let's grab this
uh last one here no moves Junior says
question is this the beginning or the
end
or what or of what the is will
ultimately become well is this the
beginning of the end it's both it's both
the beginning and the end again new
From the Ashes of the old we shall build
a new constantly cycling in many
directions at once spiraling ladies and
gentlemen if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
be the notification YouTube has been
holding back on notifications and people
are saying they weren't getting the
links so if you want to fight back
against the censorship considering the
elections you know here and
seems like the suppression is kind of on
purpose you can help by sharing the
video and becoming a member at
timcast.com to watch our uncensored
members only show we're going to be
talking about the great big titty
Ontario I was going to say Toronto
Ontario teacher conspiracy theory
it's actually really interesting so
check that out follow the show at
timcast IRL you can follow me personally
at timcastliby do you want to shout
anything out yeah I do want to shout
things out not the women's March I want
to shout out the post-millennial
thepostmillennial.com
um I want to shout out my Twitter at
Libby Emmons and also you can check out
our work at human events which is
humanevents.com and that's uh that's
that's about all of it cool so uh all my
new simps could go to lukemilkers.com
actual website which you can click right
now Luke milkers.com and you could
support me on my official members area
right there Libby I have to say I'm
sorry overwhelmingly according to the
comments you have officially lost the
milkers war you know
because what for like when you decide
you're trans yeah yeah yeah I'll do
whatever I want but all right Luke
milkers.com I've been fact-checked by
the fact Checkers so again uh
Independent Media uh Alternatives having
our own platform is key Luke milkers.com
for the for quoting the corporate media
the corporate the fake boobs no no no no
no I I literally quoted that corporate
media does not have breasts right fact
check how do you now it's trendy so it's
popular so you know you got to be ahead
of the times here and we're doing that
here at lukemilkers.com well thanks Luke
you're welcome and Ian fantastic Ian Ian
my eyes are up here okay all right
beautiful beautiful shirt uh again like
I would say hey before we roll the
Ukraine I really want to bring some hope
for these people and the people in
Russia and everyone else that's watching
and involved uh I think that what washer
wants is a piece of land that leads down
to Crimea so they have Sebastopol into
the Black Sea I don't think that it has
anything to do with genocide or or
conquering massive land Russia has never
been known for conquering land it's been
essentially a federation since the
Soviet Union split up but these two
freeways East 105 and East 97 I think uh
maybe should go to Russia in order to
avert the war
I hope that that can be some help maybe
we can start to think positively about
finding some sort of peace deal and
maybe we can get Vladimir Putin and Joe
Biden or to have some sort of dialogue
and debate discussion about what what
people want what needs to happen go from
there I love you guys thank you for
being a part of this see you later
thank you guys for joining us this
evening with our special guest Lucia
rudkowska if I got that name right I
feel like I've been thoroughly out Sean
I have no way to compete with that it's
fantastic Luke really pulls it off you
can't compete with the Lubes that's
right I know I know I can't because men
are better than women absolutely men are
better women than women I know exactly
you know it's a serious problem well
speaking of that that's going to be our
post show so you guys can follow me at
on Twitter and minds.com and Sour Patch
Lids as well as sarahpatch lids.me we
will see you all over at timcast.com
thanks for hanging out bye guys